Alright, so guys, this is the start and we need a good solid cold open. Anybody have any interesting or funny something to say? Get our listener excited to... Or surprise them. Like yeah, well it's surprising that it rained a lot yesterday. No, it will. Anything? Can you help?
0|||好的，各位，这是节目的开场，我们需要一个精彩且扎实的无铺垫开场。大家有没有什么有趣或好笑的话要说？让我们的听众兴奋起来……或者让他们感到惊讶。就像，昨天下了很多雨，这其实挺让人惊讶的。不，会的。有什么吗？你能帮帮忙吗？
No, we're still going to be digging ourselves out of a rain yesterday hole that Sean put us in. yesterday. Oh hi. Oh hi. It's OJ. I'm wearing a hat that says oh hi. I told you guys last time I was in Ohio yesterday. I just got back last night for Kevin's birthday, my friend Kevin's birthday. Oh man, what a story. You were in Ohio? Oh. Do you like it there? For whose birthday, Kevin Hart Kevin's birthday. Oh man, what a story. You were in Ohio. Do you like it there? For whose birthday, Kevin Hartz? Kevin, Kevin Neustadt, it's a friend of ours.
不，我们还在为肖恩昨天给我们挖的“昨天下雨”的坑而努力自救。昨天。哦，嗨。哦，嗨。我是OJ。我戴着一顶写着“哦，嗨”的帽子。我上次跟你们说过，我昨天在俄亥俄州。我昨晚刚回来，为了凯文的生日，我朋友凯文的生日。哦，天哪，真是个故事。你在俄亥俄州？哦。你喜欢那里吗？为了谁的生日，凯文·哈特？凯文的生日。哦，天哪，真是个故事。你在俄亥俄州。你喜欢那里吗？为了谁的生日，凯文·哈茨？凯文，凯文·诺伊施塔特，这是我们的一个朋友。
He doesn't pay attention, he doesn't remember. You mentioned Kevin and Carrie a million times, he has still no idea who they are. That's right, you've met them. Well, why would I know who they are? Because you sat and talked with Kevin for a few hours. You talked to him for a few hours, but he's not working at Netflix or show business. Do you know how many people? Because you sat and talked with Kevin for a few hours. You talked to him for a few hours, but he's not working at Netflix or any show business.
他不留心，他记不住。你提过凯文和凯莉一百万次了，他还是不知道他们是谁。没错，你见过他们。好吧，我怎么会知道他们是谁？因为你坐着和凯文聊了几个小时。你和他聊了几个小时，但他不在网飞（Netflix）或演艺圈工作。你知道有多少人……因为你坐着和凯文聊了几个小时。你和他聊了几个小时，但他不在网飞或任何演艺圈工作。
Do you know how many people you guys have sat and talked to for hours that you have no idea who they are? You can't remember them. JB, I remember you used to be somebody years ago, I won't say the gender, because I don't want to give it away, but there was somebody who you kept introducing yourself to over years and finally they got mad at you and you were like, hey, F you.
你知道你们俩坐着和多少人聊过几个小时，而你们根本不知道他们是谁吗？你们根本记不住他们。JB，我记得你多年前还是个腕儿，我不说性别，因为我不想剧透，但有那么一个人，你多年来一直向对方自我介绍，最后他们对你发火了，然后你说，嘿，去你的。
Really? You think I fucking remember it? Do you remember that? No. And eventually you're like, hey F you really you think I fucking remember it. Do you remember that? No, and eventually you're like, I don't fucking know you Well, I can't I mean I'm certainly not unique to being you know bad at remembering No, no, no, no, you're not unique. No, no, no the same same right? Yeah. I'm great at dates. You're incredible I'm good at dates, but then the names and stuff. No, no, no, same. Same. Right? But you're great at dates. You're incredible at dates. I'm good at dates, but the names and stuff, no. Yeah, dates is weird.
真的吗？你觉得我他妈能记住？你记得那个吗？不。最后你说，嘿，去你的，真的，你觉得我他妈能记住？你记得那个吗？不，最后你说，我他妈才不管你是谁呢。好吧，我不能……我是说，记性不好这种事我肯定不是独一份……不，不，不，不，你不是独一份。不，不，不，都一样，对吧？是的。我对日期很在行。你太厉害了。我对日期很在行，但名字什么的……不，不，不，都一样。都一样。对吧？但你对日期很在行。你对日期太在行了。我对日期很在行，但名字什么的，就不行了。对，日期这东西很奇怪。
I don't know what that is. And also, and I have particular trouble, guys don't typically change their look often. Present company excluded. Right. So it's not difficult for me to remember a dude's face over the course of a few years. I've had like two hairdos my whole life.
我不知道这是怎么回事。而且，我还有个特别的毛病，男士们通常不会经常换造型。在座的各位除外。没错。所以要在几年时间里记住一个男人的脸对我来说并不难。我这辈子大概就留过两种发型。
But you know, women get to change the color of their hair all the time and the cut of their hair and they accessorize. You've had a few hair don'ts too, I mean let's be honest. Oh, they're all online, you can enjoy. It is one of the worst things I ever did was, years and years and years ago, we remodeled our house and I walk out the front door and there's this girl running,
但你知道，女人们总是换发型颜色、换发型款式，还会戴各种配饰。你也留过几个“灾难”发型，我是说老实讲。哦，那些都在网上，你们可以去欣赏。我做过最糟糕的事情之一就是，好多年好多年以前，我们翻修房子，我走出了前门，然后看到一个女孩在跑步……
I may have said this already, there's this girl running down the sidewalk right towards me jogging. And she goes, hey Sean, and I'm like, hey. And she goes, you finished? Meaning to the house? And I'm like, yeah, how did they even know I was remodeling? And she goes, I'd love to see it sometime.
我可能已经说过这个了，有个女孩顺着人行道朝我这边慢跑过来。然后她说，嘿，肖恩，我说，嘿。然后她说，你弄完了吗？是指房子？我说， yeah，他们怎么知道我在装修？然后她说，我挺想找个时间看看的。
And I'm like, wait a minute. What? That's just girl jogging randomly. And I'm like, do I know you? And she goes, it's Julia, your neighbor for the past 20 years. Oh, how bad did you feel? And I said, I said Jay, I go,
然后我说，等等。什么？那只是个随便跑步的女孩。然后我说，我认识你吗？然后她说，我是朱莉娅，你过去20年的邻居。哦，你当时觉得多尴尬？然后我说，我跟杰伊说……
the worst thing you could ever come back with, I said, which was, did you change your hair? It was just terrible. It was horrible. Last week when I was in New York and I was riding a bike through the village, I'm riding along and this girl goes, Will! You're shooting additional photography for Flate?
这是你能想到的最糟糕的回应，我说，那就是：你换发型了吗？这太糟糕了。简直糟透了。上周我在纽约，我骑着自行车穿过村庄（The Village），我正骑着呢，一个女孩说，威尔！你在为《菲莱》（Flate）拍补充镜头吗？
No. And I go, and I'm riding, F you bro. And I'm riding my bike through the village and this girl goes, Will. And I look over and she goes, hey. And so I turn over, like I steer the bike over to her and I go, hey, what's going on?
不。然后我说……我骑着车，去你的兄弟。我骑着自行车穿过村庄，这个女孩说，威尔。我转过头去，她说，嘿。于是我转过身，把单车朝她骑过去，我说，嘿，怎么了？
And I'm like, who? And then she goes, I get right up closer and she goes, you don't know me. And I go. Love the show. Yeah, and so I go, okay, see you later. So then I go by, right? So then I go and it's a city bike
然后我说，谁？接着她说……我凑近了一点，她说，你不认识我。然后我说。喜欢这个节目。对，然后我说，好吧，回头见。然后我就骑过去了，对吧？接着我骑到一个城市单车（Citibike）的停车点……
and I park it in the thing and I'm walking down a block later. I'm walking by and there's this girl and guy sitting outside this place and she's wearing a baseball cap and she looks up at me and she goes, kind of waves like, hi, and I go, hey, and I keep going. I get home, there's a taxi
我把它停在桩里，过了一个街区我在往前走。我正走着，有个女孩和一个男孩坐在某个地方外面，她戴着棒球帽，抬起头看着我，然后挥了挥手，像是在说“嗨”，我说“嘿”，然后继续往前走。我回到家，有一辆出租车……
and it's this friend of mine, Emily, and she goes, did you not know that was me? So I thought I recognized the person who was a stranger, and the person I knew, I blew off. So is it just, is it just that? It's face blindness, it's face blindness. I swear I have it. Or are we just rude dicks, or are we just getting old
那是我的朋友艾米丽，她说，你不知道那是散步的我吗？所以我想我认出了一个陌生人，而我认识的人却被我冷落了。所以这到底是因为什么？这是脸盲症，这是脸盲症。我发誓我有这毛病。还是说我们只是粗鲁的混蛋，或者我们只是在变老，
and we're losing our minds? I think I've always been like that. I think it's all of it. Yeah, I think it's all of it too. Wicked combination of all of it. Yeah, but I'm terrible. I... Yo, you're the worst at, what's the subject?
然后脑子不好使了？我觉得我一直都这样。我觉得这几方面都有。是的，我也觉得这几方面都有。所有这些因素的魔鬼组合。是的，但我太差劲了。我……老兄，你最擅长的是……话题是什么？
Yeah, can we fill in the blank? Yeah, can we? Let me go first. Can I go blanket on that? You're just the worst. I kind of think everybody looks the same. I swear, I think I have a little bit of it, like face blindness, I really do.
是的，我们能填空吗？是的，可以吗？我先来。我能在这方面卡壳吗？你简直太糟糕了。我某种程度上觉得每个人长得都一样。我发誓，我觉得我有一点这方面的毛病，比如脸盲症，我真的有。
No, but that's a real thing. I know one person that's like that. Right, I think we know the same person. Yeah, I think we have a little bit of it, like face blindness, I really do. No, but that's a real thing. I know one person that's like that. Right, I think we know the same person. Yeah. Oh, yeah, I'm blanking on their face. That's a bad bow. Wonderful will. Okay, listen, listen, listen.
不，但这确实是一种真实存在的现象。我认识一个人就是这样的。对，我觉得我们认识同一个人。对，我觉得我们有一点这方面的毛病，比如脸盲症，我真的有。不，但这确实是一种真实存在的现象。我认识一个人就是这样的。对，我觉得我们认识同一个人。没错。哦，对了，我想不起他们的长相了。真是个糟糕的开场。太棒了，威尔。好了，听着，听着，听着。
Wait, wait, but I asked that guy really quick. I asked that guy, I was like, so if I walk out of the room and come back, because he has been diagnosed with face blindness, I go, if I walk out of the room and come back, because he has been diagnosed with space blindness, I go, if I walk out of the room and come back in, you won't know it's me? He's like, no. I'm like, really?
等等，等等，但我很快问过那个人。我问那个家伙，我说，如果我走出房间再进来，因为他被诊断出患有脸盲症，我说，如果我走出房间再走进来，因为他被诊断出患有空间盲症，我说，如果我走出房间再进来，你不会知道是我吗？他说，不。我说，真的吗？
And this guy's making six figures a year. I know. By the way, again, not to go too far, there is a documentary that came out in the 80s about this guy in England who had a memory of seven seconds. Poor fellow, he had an injury, head injury. And it's crazy, and his wife would like... She eventually lived on his own, had to be taken care of.
而且这人一年赚六位数。我知道。顺便说一句，再次声明，不要扯得太远，80年代出过一部纪录片，讲的是英国的一个人，他的记忆力只有七秒。可怜的家伙，他受过伤，头部受过伤。这太疯狂了，他的妻子会……他后来独自生活，必须有人照顾。
But she would go out of the room, he'd come in, she'd come in, she'd go... He'd go, hi! Oh my God! He'd hug her, hug her, hug her. She'd go to make a cup of tea, she comes back and he'd go, hello! Oh, the most annoying man to ever live with. She was the only person that he remembered. So it's on YouTube. It's fucking crazy. Can you imagine having face blindness and the seven second memory? Dude, it's the craziest, craziest thing ever.
但她会走出房间，他进来，她进来，她会……他说，嗨！天啊！他会拥抱她，拥抱她，拥抱她。她去泡杯茶，回来时他说，你好！哦，这是世上最烦人的同居伴侣。她是他唯一记得的人。所以这视频在YouTube上。太他妈疯狂了。你能想象既有脸盲症又有七秒记忆吗？老兄，这绝对是史上最疯狂、最疯狂的事情了。
Anyway, speaking of my crazy, we have a crazy talented guest on the show today. I've been looking forward to having this guest for so long. This person is, he's a true, he's a visionary. He's done everything in music and film. He's ventured into horror core. He's produced solo albums. He's made a mark in film and TV. He's scored a lot of great films.
不管怎样，说到我的疯狂，我们今天请到了一位才华横溢到疯狂的嘉宾。我期待邀请这位嘉宾很久了。这个人，他是一个真正的梦想家，一个有远见的人。他在音乐和电影领域无所不做。他涉足过硬核说唱（horror core）。他制作过个人专辑。他在电影和电视界留下了自己的印记。他为许多伟大的电影做过配乐。
He's scored Ghost Dog, The Way of the Samurai. He scored the Both Kill Bill movies. He starred last year in a award-winning comedy, Probol Mista. He's just wrapped his own film, One Spoon of Chocolate. He's a published author. He released a classical album last year, A Ballet Through the Mud, which is unbelievable.
他为《鬼狗杀手：武士之道》（Ghost Dog: The Way of the Samurai）做过配乐。他为两部《杀死比尔》（Kill Bill）电影做过配乐。他去年主演了一部获奖喜剧《Probol Mista》。他刚刚拍完自己的电影《一勺巧克力》（One Spoon of Chocolate）。他是一位出版过作品的作家。他去年发行了一张古典专辑《泥泞之中的芭蕾》（A Ballet Through the Mud），简直不可思议。
Guys, he's a titan of everything, not just the industry. He's a founding member of the Wu-Tang Clan, not only shaped the genre with their groundbreaking debut album, Enter the Wu-Tang, but he's also crafted a sound that's booming beats and chilling samples and influenced countless musicians. It's the one and only RZA, you guys. Oh, RZA!
伙计们，他是全方位的泰坦巨擘，不仅仅是在这个行业。他是武当帮（Wu-Tang Clan）的创始成员，他们不仅以突破性的首张专辑《进入武当》（Enter the Wu-Tang）塑造了这种流派，而且还打造了一种充满强劲节拍和冰冷采样、影响了无数音乐人的声音。他就是独一无二的RZA，伙计们。哦，RZA！
Whoa. Yeah. I guess I'm going to take off my camera here. There it is. Oh, boy, I have to take off my camera here. There it is! There it is. Oh boy, John Hileman's going to be thrilled. This is so cool. Hello, good morning.
哇。好吧。我想我要在这里把我的摄像头关掉。就是这样。哦，天哪，我得把我的摄像头关掉。就是这样！就是这样。哦，天哪，约翰·海勒曼（John Heileman）会激动坏的。这太酷了。你好，早安。
Good morning, good afternoon. I'm actually on the East Coast, so it's good afternoon. Happy lunch. Oh yeah. Good afternoon. Oh man, thank you for joining us today. What an absolute thrill to have you on the show today, man. Oh, My pleasure.
早上好，下午好。我其实在东海岸，所以是下午好。午餐愉快。哦，是的。下午好。哦天哪，谢谢你今天能来。今天能请你上节目，真是太激动了，老兄。哦，我的荣幸。
And I will start off by saying, I have a great memory, all right? Yeah? We're the same age. Exactly. Will you remember for me right now what it was like to score both Kill Billz? I mean, that's like, was that the only film that you,
我首先要说的是，我记性很好，好吧？是吗？我们同龄。没错。你现在能为我回忆一下，为两部《杀死比尔》配乐是什么感觉吗？我的意思是，那就像……那是你唯一的电影……
the films that you've scored? No, that was, no, that you've scored? Did you do- No, I went on to score maybe a dozen after that in some TV shows, et cetera. Do you love that? Yeah, scoring is the ultimate, one of the ultimate expressions of art, right? You're trying to tell a story and compliment a story
你做过配乐的电影？不，那是……不，你做过配乐的？你做过——不，在那之后我又接着为十几部作品以及一些电视剧等做过配乐。你喜欢那样吗？是的，配乐是终极的、艺术的终极表达方式之一，对吧？你试图通过你的音乐来讲述一个故事并为主题增色，是的，我喜欢。
with your music, yes, I love it. Yeah, but sometimes the cues have to only be 10, 20, 30 seconds or do you feel like you're boxed in with that? Yeah, I think to be quite frank, you may have a cue that's just a cymbal. That's your cue, right? Yeah, yeah.
是的，但有时音乐片断（cues）必须只有10秒、20秒、30秒，你觉得自己被这种形式束缚住了吗？是的，坦白说，你可能会有一个只有一声镲片敲击的片断。那就是你的片断，对吧？对，对。
But you may have one that's a whole Nutcracker suite, you know what I mean? Whole big sequence. So, I mean, that's the beauty of music. You think about, I mean, one of our great composers, John Williams, he was, do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do. And that's just a few notes. Yeah, yeah.
但你也可能会有一个像整部《胡桃夹子》组曲那样的，你知道我的意思吗？整整一大段序列。所以，这就是音乐的美妙之处。你想想，我们的伟大作曲家之一，约翰·威廉姆斯（John Williams），他是，咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚-咚。而那仅仅是几个音符。对，对。
That's so awesome. So was Ghost Dog Way of the Samurai, was that your first one that you did? Yeah, so Jim John Moose brought me in to score that film. I never scored a film before, I was pretty, I didn't know what it was to be honest with you. I didn't know, when you make a movie, you gotta edit, you gotta do all these things, right?
太棒了。那么《鬼狗杀手：武士之道》，那是你做的第一部作品吗？是的，吉姆·贾木许（Jim Jarmusch）找我为那部电影做配乐。我以前从未给电影做过配乐，我当时挺……老实说我不知道那是什么。我不知道，当你拍电影时，你得剪辑，你得做所有这些事情，对吧？
And Jim used to want the music, and he'd be like, come to the editing room, which is basically, the editing is a nine to five job, maybe a nine to eight. I'd be coming like midnight, you know what I mean? Everybody'd be gone, but at those days, we had the music on the DAT, so I would just have it on the DAT player,
吉姆以前总想要音乐，他会说：来剪辑室吧，基本上剪辑是个朝九晚五的工作，也许是朝九晚八。我大概半夜才去，你知道我的意思吗？所有人都走了，但在那些日子里，我们将音乐存在DAT（数字音频磁带）上，所以我只要带着DAT播放器，
pull up to the place and give him the DAT, so he'd be like, you know, it's midnight. I'm like, well, you know, here it is. Why is that? Why is it historically, you know, music studio sessions late in the night? What is that? I don't understand.
开车到那个地方把DAT交给他，他就会说，你知道的，都半夜了。我说，好吧，你看，这就是了。这是为什么？为什么历史上音乐录音室的录音时间总是在深夜？这是怎么回事？我不明白。
Beats so high. Yeah, musicians, yeah. You guys have like a different clock. Yeah, I mean, my musician clock was ridiculous. I mean, it was embarrassing to be quite frank. I remember as I'm scoring movies, I started sampling some music from one of John Woo's movies, The Killer, which one of my favorite, The Killer,
节拍太高了。是的，音乐人，是的。你们的生理时钟跟别人不一样。对，我的音乐人生理时钟太荒谬了。坦白说，这挺尴尬的。我记得当我在为电影做配乐时，我开始采样约翰·吴（John Woo，吴宇森）的一部电影《喋血双雄》（The Killer）中的音乐，那是我最喜欢的电影之一，《喋血双雄》，
a hard boil, great. Yeah, great movies. Great titles by the great director, John Woo. And we became friends and he came to New York and he's like, you know, I want to have, let's have dinner. And I said, cool, let's have dinner. So I meet you at the restaurant, you know, 630 in Manhattan. And at the time I was in the studio
还有《辣手神探》（Hard Boiled），太棒了。是的，伟大的电影。伟大导演吴宇森带来的伟大片名。我们成了朋友，他来到纽约，他说，你知道，我想吃个饭。我说，酷，我们吃晚饭吧。于是我在曼哈顿一家餐厅跟你见面，你知道的，6点半。当时我正在离那儿大约一小时车程的录音室里，
that was like an hour away and I just got caught up in the studio. And then it's like nine o'clock, they're like, wait, you're supposed to be at dinner with John. And I'm like, okay. Yeah, you kind of get sucked into it and it's like this, like, yeah, my husband, Scotty, he also composes scores and stuff for us.
然后我就在录音室里走不开。接着差不多九点钟了，他们说，等等，你不是应该去和约翰吃晚饭吗？我说，好吧。是的，你有点被吸进去了，然后就像这样……是的，我丈夫斯科蒂（Scotty），他也会为我们作曲和做配乐之类的。
And he'll be back there in like eight hours fly by. You don't even know if, you know. But John was such a gentleman, showing that I got there around 11 and he held the restaurant open and he sat down and had a great meal. Oh, that's amazing. And he gave me some wisdom about time. Well, I was going to say, some wisdom about time,
他在后面呆八个小时一晃就过去了。你甚至都不知道……但约翰真是个绅士，看我11点左右才到，他让餐厅一直开着门，坐下来陪我吃了一顿丰盛的大餐。哦，那太棒了。他跟我讲了一些关于时间的智慧。嗯，我是说，关于时间的智慧，
I like that expression. About time, which is so funny, because all music is in time. Is all time. And we're all late. So it's funny, Rizzo, when I think about it, because I was asking about the first film that you scored, which was Ghost Dog, and I was going to say, how did you get into it? But it makes sense, because I was asking about the first film that you scored, which was Ghost Dog,
我喜欢这个说法。关于时间，这太有趣了，因为所有的音乐都在时间里。所有时间都是。而我们全都迟到了。所以很有趣，Rza，当我想起这件事时，因为我问过你做的第一部电影配乐是什么，也就是《鬼狗杀手》，我本想说，你是怎么入行的？但这就说得通了，因为我刚才问的是你做的第一部电影配乐，也就是《鬼狗杀手》，
and I was going to say, how did you get into it? But it makes sense, because you mentioned John Woo's films being a huge influence. I mean, there's a cinematic influence in the Wu-Tang music, right? I mean, that's part of your origin story. Can you talk a little bit about that?
我本想说，你是怎么入行的？但这就说得通了，因为你提到吴宇森的电影对你产生了巨大的影响。我是说，武当帮的音乐里有一种电影般的质感，对吧？我的意思是，那是你起源故事的一部分。你能稍微谈谈那个吗？
Yeah, I mean, my aspirations at the time of making music was trying to make a movie, trying to make my album play like a movie. In New York, a lot of us kind of would drive to DC, to the Howard Homecoming, or to Morgan State College, or go off to Connecticut. That's the weekend thing to do, right? That's where the chicks are at. Yeah. And my idea was to make people who are driving that journey,
是的，我的意思是，我当时做音乐的宏愿就是试图拍一部电影，试图让我的专辑听起来像一部电影。在纽约，我们很多人会开车去华盛顿特区参加霍华德大学的返校节（Homecoming），或者去摩根州立大学，或者去康涅狄格州。那是周末常做的事，对吧？辣妹都在那儿。是的。我的想法是让那些开车进行这段旅程的人，
to listen to my music and to get a movie in their head and pick up some game, pick up some slang, pick up some visions. So I was always trying to make movies and on my first five albums, if you listen to them, they always start with a beginning, there's a theme. There's an album we did called Cuban Links, which is really a mafia movie.
听着我的音乐，脑海中浮现出一部电影，并学到一些行话、学到一些俚语、看到一些愿景。所以我一直在尝试制作电影，如果你们听一下我的前五张专辑，它们总是从一个开端开始，有一个主题。我们做过一张名为《古巴血脉》（Cuban Links）的专辑，那真是一部黑手党电影。
It starts off with three guys, one for you, one for me, one guy cheating on them. It's like, you know the old thing, one for you, one for me, two for you, one, two for me, three for you. And it goes on, and the way the album plays out, it's like these guys are going to pull a heist, somebody's going to die, like once upon a time in America. The other two guys are going to go grab the rest of the crew, the Wu Gambino's, bring them back,
它一开始是三个家伙，一个给你，一个给我，其中一个家伙背叛了他们。就像……你知道那个老梗，一个给你，一个给我，两个给你，一、两个给我，三个给你。然后继续发展，整张专辑的走向就像是这群家伙要去干一票劫案，有人会死，就像《美国往事》（Once Upon a Time in America）一样。另外两个家伙去召集剩下的成员——武当帮洛杉矶/黑手党分支（Wu Gambinos），把他们带回来，
and then pull a bigger heist for two million, and everybody's going to ride off into the sunset. And that album was so influential that hip hop began to change their names. Like we was the first ones to change their names, like from Wu-Tang to the Wu-Gang-Binos, and every artist started following that trend. Wow.
然后干一票两百万美元更大的劫案，最后所有人骑着马消失在夕阳中。那张专辑太有影响力了，以至于嘻哈界开始改名字。就像我们是第一批改名字的人，从武当（Wu-Tang）改成武当帮（Wu-Gambinos），每个艺术家都开始效仿这个潮流。哇。
Wow, wow, that's so cool. I mean, so you guys, so I mentioned in the intro that in 93 you guys released Enter the Wu Tang and that kind of changed the game. Certainly must have changed your life in a big way. You had already been making music for years, right, with those guys? Yeah.
哇，哇，太酷了。我是说，你们这些人……我在开场白里提过，93年你们发行了《进入武当》，这改变了游戏规则。这肯定在很大程度上改变了你们的生活。你之前已经和那些家伙一起做音乐好多年了，对吧？是的。
But that was the first big release that went kind of crazy. Must have, what was that experience like? Yeah, it was, I tried to enter the industry before just as a solo artist, Prince Rakeem, sold about 10,000 records, got a couple of shows and a couple of groupies. Right? That was at that age, 19 years old, that's not a bad start. But yeah, right.
但那是第一张有点疯狂的发行。那一定……那种经历是怎样的？是的，我之前曾试图以个人艺术家的身份进入这个行业，当时叫Prinz Rakeem，卖了大约1万张唱片，做过几场演出，还有几个饭圈女孩（groupies）。对吧？在那个年纪，19岁，这算是个不错的开始。但是，对吧。
Couldn't pay my rent though. But I went back to my crew and I was just like, we have this thing in the neighborhood called the Wu Tang Sling. And we was all big kung fu movie lovers. And I just called it inspiration that we should take with our childhood love, take the concept of Asian cinema from Hong Kong or from Japan. And since our lyrics are from your mouth and your mouth is like a sword, right?
不过付不起房租。但我回到了我的团队，然后我就觉得：我们在社区里有一种叫做“武当俚语”的东西。我们都是功夫电影的超级爱好者。我只是觉得这是一种灵感，我们应该把我们童年对功夫的热爱融入其中，采用来自香港或日本的亚洲电影的概念。既然我们的歌词来自你的嘴，而你的嘴就像一把剑，对吧？
It says that in the book of Revelations. It says, out of the mouth comes a double edged sword. So I was like, if we take our tongue and make it our sword and the best sword style ever filmed was the Wu-Tang style and we become the Wu-Tang clan, we could go into the industry and chop everybody heads off. You know, my brothers was like, sounds good to me.
启示录里就是这么说的。它说，口中出来一把两刃的剑。所以我想，如果我们把我们的舌头当作我们的剑，而拍过的最好的剑术风格又是武当风格，我们变成了武当帮，我们就能进入这个行业，把所有人的脑袋都砍下来。你知道的，我的兄弟们觉得：听起来不错。
Yeah. Well, that was my question because I'm a dumb, soft white guy from Los Angeles and I not know about... Well, you know, I'm not... No, that's very true. That's a really apt description of you. I'm not, as the you know, I'm not. No, that's very true. That's a really apt description of you. I'm not, as the kids say, I'm not down. I'm not hip to it all.
嗯，那是我的问题，因为我是一个来自洛杉矶的愚蠢、温和的白人，我不知道……嗯，你知道，我不是……不，这很真实。这真是对你非常贴切的描述。我不是，正如孩子们所说，我不是“道中中人”。我对这一切都不太懂。
And so I'm not clear on Asian cinema, on Kung Fu, on the genesis of the title of the band and stuff. So I was going to ask you about that. How, so how did your love of Kung Fu and Asian films, and how does that start? Because you wouldn't necessarily put hip hop with Asian cinema in the same group, right? Typically?
所以我对亚洲功夫电影、功夫、乐队名字的由来等等一无所知。所以我本来想问你这个。那么，你对功夫和亚洲电影的热爱是如何开始的？因为你通常不会把嘻哈和亚洲电影归为同一类，对吧？通常情况下？
I mean, you kind of have to, if you think about it, right? If you go back into hip hop, according to hip hop history, it says it started in 1973, in that summer. But in that same summer, Bruce Lee Enter the Dragon hits 42nd Street. And that same summer, Fred Williams and Black Caesar hits. And also The Godfather is in the theaters. Mean Streets, right? So the art of the cinema is still cohesive
我的意思是，如果你仔细想想，你还真得把它们归为一类，对吧？如果你回到嘻哈音乐中，根据嘻哈历史，它始于1973年那个夏天。但在同个夏天，李小龙的《龙争虎斗》（Enter the Dragon）登陆了第42街。而在同个夏天，弗雷德·威廉姆斯的《黑撒加》（Black Caesar）上映了。还有《教父》（The Godfather）也在各大影院上映。《穷街陋巷》（Mean Streets），对吧？所以电影艺术与音乐艺术仍然是息息相关的。
with the art of the music. There's actually a thread because most of us are in those theaters. And then when we go back to our neighborhoods, the things that we are gaining from cinema is finding its way into our art. If you look at some of the early breakdance moves, you'll see that some of those moves were seen
这其中其实有一条线索，因为我们大多数人都泡在那些电影院里。然后当我们回到社区时，我们从电影中汲取的东西开始融入我们的艺术中。如果你看看一些早期的霹雳舞动作，你会发现其中一些动作是在武术电影中出现过的，当然，随后他们将其提升到了另一个水平。
in a martial art film, and then of course took it to another level. Yeah, that's amazing. I didn't think of that. That's so true. Of course you didn't think of that. But you're dumb. You're dumb.
是的，太惊人了。我没想到这一点。确实如此。你当然想不到这一点。因为你很蠢。你很蠢。
You think about a lot. What do you know, dude? You don't know anything. Listen to the rhythm and learn, okay? That is true. Break dancing is, yeah, you could duck a lot of punches, yeah. And kicks down there on the floor. So then, so that makes sense.
你想得挺多。你懂个屁，老兄？你什么都不懂。听着节奏学着点，好吧？这倒没错。霹雳舞嘛，是的，你在地板上可以躲过很多拳头。还有地上的踢腿。所以这就说得通了。
And so then you guys do, you produce and you form Wu-Tang and you release some records and just a huge, like massively influential but also what's interesting to me is and tell these guys and educate all of us a little bit about Not only were you guys doing Wu-Tang but then as you're doing I mean you're doing all sorts of solo projects under a bunch of different names, right? And you mentioned Prince Rakeem, which was your uh that you released before, but also some stuff after, right, as well, and also, but also other guys from Wu-Tang, you produced their stuff.
然后你们就这么做了，你们制作并组建了武当帮，发行了一些唱片，不仅产生了巨大且深远的影响，而且对我来说有趣的是——告诉这些家伙，也给我们大家科普一下——你们不仅在做武当帮，而且在做的同时……我是说你们在用一堆不同的名字做各种各样的个人项目，对吧？你提到了Prinz Rakeem，那是你之前发行的，但之后也有一些作品，对吧？还有武当帮的其他成员，你也为他们的作品担任制作人。
Like oftentimes people leave a band and go and do something on their own, on their own, on their own, but you were still producing everybody's music. Is that true? Yeah. I was with, so since the martial art world or the Shaolin philosophy was so embedded in us,
就像通常人们离开乐队后会单飞，各自做各自的事情，但你还在为每个人的音乐担任制作人。这是真的吗？是的。我和……由于武术世界或少林哲学已经深深植根于我们心中，
we took it and applied it to our lives. So for instance, Staten Island, my hometown, we renamed it Shaolin. You know what I mean? That's why you see Pete Davidson has a Shaolin tattoo of course. Oh wow. He's from Staten Island, but we renamed it Shaolin. So Shaolin is considered the temple, the well, they would say, from which all martial arts springs from. It's the strongest philosophy place that even before Zen made it to Japan, it was developed in Shaolin.
我们接受了它并将其应用到我们的生活中。例如，斯塔滕岛（Staten Island），我的家乡，我们把它重命名为“少林”。你知道我的意思吗？这就是为什么你会看到皮特·戴维森（Pete Davidson）有一个少林纹身。哦，哇。他是斯塔滕岛人，但我们把它重命名为少林。所以少林被认为是寺庙，用他们的话说，是所有武术发源的源泉。它是最强大的哲学圣地，甚至在禅宗传入日本之前，它就在少林发展起来了。
And so in Shaolin, they had the monks, but the leader of the monks was called the Abbot. And so my Wu-Tang brothers called me the Abbot. You know what I mean? So now, as the Abbot, it's my job to make the best decisions, the best direction of which way we go. And as the producer, I went on to produce, of course, the first album, 36 Chambers, it went platinum. So going platinum, of course, is a bong bong, right?
因此，在少林，他们有僧侣，但僧侣的领袖被称为“方丈”（Abbot）。所以我的武当兄弟们叫我“方丈”。你知道我的意思吗？现在，作为方丈，我的工作是做出最好的决定，为我们前进的方向指明最佳路径。作为制作人，我接着制作了第一张专辑《36房》（36 Chambers），它获得了白金销量。所以获得白金销量，当然是个大满贯，对吧？
So then after that, of course, is a bong bong, right? So then after that, of course, I became a sought after producer. But what I did was to keep my energy contained within my crew. So I went on to produce Method Man's first album, Double Platinum, Freak Ron Platinum, Old Dirty Bastard Platinum, Jizzah Platinum, Ghostface Platinum. So he said- That's unbelievable. Yeah, so I might have did about seven platinum albums
所以在此之后……当然是个大满贯，对吧？所以在那之后，我理所当然地成了一个炙手可热的制作人。但我做的是将我的能量凝聚在我的团队内部。所以我接着制作了方法人（Method Man）的第一张专辑双白金，拜师（Raekwon）白金，老肮脏混蛋（Ol' Dirty Bastard）白金，Genius/GZA白金，鬼脸煞星（Ghostface）白金。所以他说——这太难以置信了。是的，所以我大概连续制作了大约七张白金专辑。
back to back. I don't think too many people probably did that. So that's a blessing. But it was a contained energy, you know what I mean? I remember talking to Seth Rogan when they had their breakout. He made a joke because him and his crew who were listeners of the Wu-Tang Clan,
我想没有多少人能做到这一点。所以这是一种祝福。但这是一股内聚的能量，你知道我的意思吗？我记得跟塞斯·罗根（Seth Rogan）聊天时，他们迎来了爆发。他开玩笑说，因为他和他的团队都是武当帮的听众，
they called themselves the Ju-Tang Clan, he said. Right? And he said they all lived together, and him and Evan and everybody. They actually took that concept and did the same thing, and continued, hit after hit. And I think that's a great thing for any group of artists
他们自称为“犹当帮”（Ju-Tang Clan），他说。对吧？他说他们都住在一起，他和埃文（Evan）以及所有人。他们实际上采用了这个概念并做了同样的事情，一首接一首地推出热门歌曲。我认为这对于任何艺术家组合来说都是一件了不起的事情，
is if you could combine that art together and then direct it as a brand, you will increase your fan base of course, but also give each one of you a chance to go through the same tunnel. That is so cool, I love that. There's a sort of like, sort of like a,
如果你能把这种艺术结合起来，然后作为品牌来运营，你当然会增加你的粉丝基础，但也会给你们每个人一个机会去经历相同的历程。太酷了，我喜欢这个。这有点像……
you harness the power of the collective a little bit, and you don't let it dissipate, you kind of keep it, and you all kind of move, and then all boats rise, right? You know what I mean? What would we call our little clan here? Like the Chin Chin clan. The Smart Clans.
你多少驾驭了集体力量，不让它消散，你把它凝聚起来，你们一起前进，然后水涨船高，对吧？你知道我的意思吗？我们该给我们这个小帮派起个什么名字呢？比如“金金帮”（Chin Chin Clan）。“聪明帮”（Smart Clans）。
Yeah, I don't know. By the way, you mentioned. I really like Chin Chin. Well, Chin Chin went out of business, did you see that? Well, no, they just shut down the sunset. They just shut down the one on Sunset. They did, they shut down the one on Beverly Hills too. Sorry, Sean.
是的，我不知道。顺便说一句，你提到……我真的很喜欢“金金”。好吧，“金金”倒闭了，你看到了吗？哦，没有，他们只是关了日落大道（Sunset）那家。他们关了，日落大道那家关了。他们把比弗利山庄那家也关了。抱歉，肖恩。
Get through the interview and oh my God. You'll get your sodium somewhere else, don't worry about that. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So you talk about Shaolin, I didn't know any of that. That is such a cool concept, dude. I'm so blown away by it, I'm like riveted.
熬过采访，哦天哪。你在别的地方也能摄入钠，别担心那个。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。所以你谈到少林，我对此一无所知。这真是一个太酷的概念了，老兄。我被迷得神魂颠倒，我简直入迷了。
And you guys recorded your seventh album was Once Upon a Time in Shaolin, right? And you made one copy. Do you guys know about this story, Sean and Jason? Do you know about this? No, no, no, no, no. Can you tell these guys a little bit about it? Because it's one of the coolest stories in art history.
你们录制的第七张专辑是《少林寺童话》（Once Upon a Time in Shaolin），对吧？你们只制作了一份拷贝。肖恩和杰森，你们知道这个故事吗？你们知道这个吗？不，不，不，不。你能给这些家伙讲讲吗？因为这是艺术史上最酷的故事之一。
Forget music. Oh wait, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's so, it's so bad. And then that guy did with a controversial purchase of it, correct? I don't know this, I don't know this. Yes, a very controversial purchase. Please, please tell me.
别提音乐了。哦等等，对，对，对。这太……太糟糕了。然后那家伙进行了有争议的购买，对吧？我不知道这个，我不知道这个。是的，一次非常有争议的购买。请，请告诉我。
Will you tell these guys what happened, what that album was about, and why you did it all? Okay, first, you know, once streaming took over music, you know, music went from being worth two cent of record spend on your radio to being worth zero, zero, zero, zero point four. Okay? And so it was totally devalued
你能告诉这些家伙发生了什么，那张专辑是关于什么的，以及你为什么要这么做吗？好吧，首先，你知道的，自从流媒体接管音乐界以来，音乐的价值从在电台播放一张唱片值两美分变成了零、零、零、零点四。好吧？所以它被彻底贬值了，
and a lot of artists were suffering because of that devaluation at this time. And for me- Napster. Pardon? Napster. If you think about Napster, that was the foundation of that devaluation at this time. And for me- Napster. Pardon? Napster. If you think about Napster, that was the foundation of- He'll bark out moments of knowledge every once in a while.
当时的许多艺术家都在这种贬值中遭受痛苦。对我和我来说——Napster。什么？Napster。如果你想想Napster，那就是这种贬值的基石。而对我和我来说——Napster。什么？Napster。如果你想想Napster，那就是——他偶尔会爆发出一些知识的碎片。
You're like my grandmother in the other room, and you're like, Napster! Napster! Wait, I know that! That was the first one, yeah. After everything got devalued, we tried to figure out a way to bring value back to music. And the idea was music
你就像坐在隔壁房间的我奶奶，在那喊：Napster！Napster！等等，我知道那个！那是第一个，对吧。在一切都被贬值之后，我们试图找出一种方法，把价值带回音乐中。当时的想法是，音乐
is art and it should be treated as such. And it's not something that, it's not just a privilege, right? Because the creation of it is such a process. Like for a Wu-Tang album to make it, you got to get nine to 20 people together, the engineers. And it's an endeavor, like a film, right? It costs a lot of money, right, to make it. And then the goal is to sell it so you can continue to make it again. You know what I mean? So anyway, it got so devalued that we was like,
就是艺术，应该受到艺术般的对待。它不是某种……它不仅仅是一种特权，对吧？因为它的创作是一个漫长的过程。就像制作一张武当专辑，你必须让9到20个人聚在一起，还有工程师。这是一项宏大的工程，就像拍电影一样，对吧？制作它需要花很多钱，对吧？然后目标是把它卖出去，这样你才能继续创作。你知道我的意思吗？所以无论如何，它被贬值得太厉害了，以至于我们觉得，
well, let's make an album that will make one single copy, treat it like it's a Mona Lisa or an Egyptian scepter, something like that. It belonged in a museum. And the only way that you can now get it, you have to go to it. You have to go see it. This is amazing.
好吧，让我们制作一张专辑，只做唯一的一份拷贝，把它当作蒙娜丽莎或埃及权杖那样对待。它应该属于博物馆。而你现在唯一能听到它的方法，就是亲自去找它。你得去看它。这太惊人了。
Oh, that's cool. And we auctioned it. The funny thing is when we auctioned it, we auctioned it to a guy named Mike Scarelli. Yeah. Now, Scarelli, at the time when he bought the album, I gotta confess this, because I don't talk about this a lot,
哦，那太酷了。而且我们把它拍卖了。有趣的是，当我们拍卖它时，我们把它卖给了一个叫迈克·斯卡雷利（Mike Scarelli）的人。是的。现在，斯卡雷利买下这张专辑的时候，我得坦白这一点，因为我不太谈论这个，
at the time I shook his hand, he wasn't known yet. Like I met him, it was a few different billionaires that was going to buy this album from this Sotheby's, Padaway auction type of thing. And he was probably the poorest amongst them.
在我跟他握手的时候，他当时还不出名。我遇到他时，有几个不同的亿万富翁打算从苏富比（Sotheby's）、帕达韦（Padaway）这种类型的拍卖会上买下这张专辑。他可能是他们当中最穷的一个。
He only worth about 200 million at the time. But he was into it, right? And he told me, he said, I'm going to buy the last Enigma machine. I'm going to buy the churning papers. And I'm going to buy your single album all in one week. And I'm going to take this and I'm going to create something that's going to, for him, he's going to become like a new supervillain or something. He did say villain though, but he was like, he's going to take these elements and he's
他当时身家只有大约2亿。但他对这很感兴趣，对吧？他告诉我，他说：我要买最后一台恩尼格玛密码机（Enigma machine）。我要买丘吉尔的文件。我要在一周内把你们的这张单拷贝专辑全买下来。我要拿走这些，然后我要创造一些东西，对他来说，他要变成某种新的超级反派之类的人。不过他确实说了“反派”这个词，他说他要利用这些元素，
going to create something crazy. And he went and formed this company, the turning company, et cetera, et cetera. And I shook hands on him. In that same company, a few months later, before we announced the purchase and everything, because we had a scheduled date of closing, is that how we call it, a few months later, before we announced the purchase and everything because we had a scheduled date of closing, is that what we call it, a few months later, this guy shows up on the news as the evilest man in the world.
创造出一些疯狂的东西。然后他去成立了这家公司，叫图灵公司（Turing company）等等等等。我跟他握了手。在同一家公司，几个月后，在我们宣布购买消息以及所有事情之前——因为我们有一个预定的交割日期，这是我们当时的说法吗？——几个月后，这家伙在新闻上露面了，成了世界上最邪恶的人。
Yeah, yeah. He took the price of a medicine that was maybe $15 a pill. Oh, that guy, that guy, whoever that guy. And he turned it to $2,000, $4,000 a pill. And the saddest thing about it was that this pill was for our citizens who have HIV. Right, I remember that, yeah. It was a dire need for this pill for them.
对，对。他把一粒原本可能15美元的药丸的价格……哦，那个家伙，那个家伙，管他是谁。他把它涨到了2,000美元、4,000美元一粒。最可悲的是，这药是给我们那些患有艾滋病的同胞准备的。对，我记得那个，是的。他们极其需要这种药。
And so basically, he was burning down a village, I mean you could put it to that analogy, that he's burning down villages by this price gouging. But he had already purchased that album, so now. Yeah, so now you're stuck. So now I have to, he sells it. And then I did say this to him though, I said, listen, sorry his name was Martin Scrutty.
所以基本上，他在毁灭一个村庄，你可以用这个比喻来形容，他通过这种哄抬物价的行为在毁灭村庄。但他已经买下了那张专辑，所以现在……是的，所以现在你被套牢了。所以我不得不……他把它卖了。不过我确实对他说过这样的话，我说，听着，抱歉，他叫马丁·斯克鲁蒂（Martin Scrutty）。
I said, listen Martin, you do a lot of bad things, bro. The Wu-Tang is good, okay? If I was you, I would take this album and do something good with it, meaning he could give it to the people. It can't be sold because we made an 88 year non-commercialization law for it, so he can't sell it. Right, he can't sell it. Right?
我说，听着，马丁，你干了很多坏事，老兄。武当是善良的，好吗？如果我是你，我会拿着这张专辑用它做点好事，意思是你可以把它送给人们。它不能出售，因为我们为它制定了88年的非商业化法律，所以他不能卖。对，他不能卖。对吧？
He can't like make mass producers. I know it's so cool. That is amazing. But he didn't decide to do nothing good. He went, he doubled down on his darkness and he got into a big fight with Ghostface Killer and all the other Wu-Tang brothers. And then he, you know, he took Hillary's hair
他不能像批量生产那样。我知道这太酷了。太棒了。但他决定什么好事都不做。他继续一意孤行，将黑暗进行到底，并与鬼脸煞星（Ghostface Killa）和其他所有武当兄弟发生了激烈的争执。然后他，你知道的，他拿希拉里的头发开玩笑……不管怎样，他一路作死，直到进了监狱。然后政府没收了这张专辑并将其扣押。接着，他为这张专辑付了两百万。所以当时它是历史上最贵的专辑。但当他入狱时，政府现在需要支付他所有的留置权或违约判决，或者他身上的任何债务，所以政府现在可以作为他的个人资产拍卖这张专辑，好吧？
and whatever, he just went all the way down until he went to jail. And then the government seized the album and they kept it. And then, so he paid two million for the album. So at the time it was the most expensive album in history. But when he went to jail, the government now needed to pay all of his liens or default judgments, whatever he had on him And so the government now gets to auction this album as a personal asset of his okay
好吧，他们把它拿去拍卖，有人以四百万美元买下了它。哇，行吧。好吧。好吧。哼，你知道什么？那谁买到了？它现在在哪？有一群人叫做“Pleaser DAO”，好吧。所以，现在是谁买到了，它在哪？有一群人叫做“Pleaser DAO”。好吧。所以他们现在拥有它，希望他们能采纳将它展示给大众、把它放进博物馆的建议。是的，他们不是办过一次展览什么的，把它带到塔斯马尼亚（Tasmania）之类的地方了吗？
All right, they auction it and someone buys it for four million dollars. Wow way Okay. Okay. Yeah, what do you know? So who's got it? And where is it? It was a group of people called the pleaser Dow Okay Right now, so who's got it and where is it? There's a group of people called the Pleaser Dow. Okay. So they have it now and they're just, hopefully they will take the advice of showing it to the people, putting it in museums. Yeah, didn't they do an exhibit or something, they took it to somewhere like Tasmania or something?
是真的吗？是的，他们把它带到塔斯马尼亚并进行了展览。你说得对，是的。人们为此特意飞过去。那么公众有机会听到它吗？到目前为止，大概有600人听过。老兄。太惊人了。
Is that true? Yeah, they took it to Tasmania and exhibited it. You're right, yeah. And people flew in for that. So has the public been able to hear it? So far, maybe about 600 people have heard it. Dude. That's amazing.
像你这样……这是一个不可思议的故事。你如何保护拥有它的人不被复制，然后……我不知道，它就这样泄露了，或者，你知道的，他们，然后他们采取了，你知道的，这种……嗯，有合同。这是一个……这个特定的专辑在宏观层面上被认为是第一个NFT。啊，非常好，我明白了。
Like how do you, that's an incredible story. How do you protect the person who owns it from copying it and kind of, I don't know, it just got leaked or, you know, they, and then they act, you know, in this kind of. Well, there's a contract. There's a, it's, this particular album is on a macro level considered the first NFT. Ah, very good, I understand.
如果你懂的话，是的，这就是它的情况。所以它里面内置了智能合约，你知道我的意思吗？而这是你的主意。我的意思是，这是一个如此不可思议、具有前瞻性的想法。我知道，我知道。这太 brilhant（绝妙）了。我和我的学生Silverings，我不会独占所有功劳，
So if you understand, yeah, so that's the situation with it. And so it's like a smart contract built in, you know what I mean? And this was your idea. I mean, it's such an incredible forward-thinking idea. I know, I know. It's brilliant. Me and my student Silverings, I won't take all the credit,
这是多种想法结合的产物。是的，你还会再这样做吗？我不知道。电台司令（Radiohead）做过的一件事怎么样，他们制作了一张专辑并把它免费放到网上，基本上说，想付多少就付多少。而那种自由让我——我想我最后为它付了50美元
it was a combination of ideas that led to it. Yeah, and would you ever do it again? I don't know. What about what Radiohead did something was where they made an album and they put it up on the internet for free, basically said, pay whatever you want. And that kind of freedom made me, I think I ended up paying like 50 bucks for it
或者类似的东西。就像……如果你告诉我我什么都不用做，那我就会去做。那是完美的事情。你真是个十足的冤大头，老兄。完全正确。你知道我的意思吗？这就是为什么你的外号叫DJ冤大头（DJ Sucka）。
or something like that. Like just like, if you tell me I don't have to do anything, then I'll do it. That was the perfect thing. You're the perfect sucker, man. Exactly. You know what I mean? That's why your nickname is DJ Sucka.
诸如此类的话。就像，如果你告诉我我什么都不用做，那我就去做了。这简直太完美了。你真是个大冤种，伙计。完全正确。你知道我的意思吗？这就是为什么你的外号叫DJ冤种。
Ding bet. Hey, hey. I mean, God, that is such a, you're right. Sean, like you said, it's so forward thinking. And you've, I mean, God, that is such a, you're right, Sean, like you said, it's so forward thinking, and you've, I mean, you constantly have looked for different ways to express yourself as an artist and kind of do things outside the box. You've acted in, I was looking it up, I mean, I don't know,
Ding，没错。嘿，嘿。我是说，天哪，这真是，你说得对。肖恩，就像你说的，这太有前瞻性了。而且你，我是说，天哪，这真是，你说得对，肖恩，就像你说的，这太有前瞻性了，而且你，我是说，你作为一名艺术家，一直在寻找不同的方式来表达自己，有点像在做一些打破常规的事情。你出演过，我刚刚查了一下，我是说，不知道，
50 things, 60 things as an actor? You just, tell us a little bit about your film that's coming out that you directed. Thank you. First let me say this to y'all gentlemen. First of all, Jason, big fan of yours. Come on. Yeah, there we go.
50部，60部电影作为演员？你能不能跟我们简单聊聊你即将上映的、由你执导的电影。谢谢。首先，我要对在座各位先生说这番话。首先，杰森，我是你的超级粉丝。来吧。对，就是这样。
Your timing, your style. Nice man, you. I watch, I watch. Hey. I've seen almost everything you do and so just want to let you know that. That's very nice. You got a fan on this side of the microphone.
你的节奏感，你的风格。太棒了，老兄，你。我有看，我有看。嘿。你几乎所有的作品我都看过，所以只想让你知道这一点。这真是太好了。麦克风这头有一位你的粉丝。
Thank you, pal. And for myself let you know that. You got a fan on the side of the microphone. Thank you, pal. And for myself, you know, I got a chance to study underneath Quentin Tarantino for about six years. And I caught the directing bug and understood what it could be. And I did my first film, of course, in 2011. Came out 2012, called The Man with the Iron Fist. And I realized that directing movies
谢谢你，老兄。至于我自己，让你知道这一点。麦克风这头有一位粉丝。谢谢你，老兄。还有我呢，你知道，我有幸师从昆汀·塔伦蒂诺大约六年。我迷上了导演，并明白了这门艺术的真谛。当然，我在2011年拍摄了我的第一部电影。2012年上映，名叫《铁拳》。我意识到拍电影
is actually the epitome of expression art because you have to be lyrical in the words, colorful in the production design and costume design. Music is a part of it. The storytelling element, the energy of getting other people to portray an idea that's written and describe it, it's like the total use of my brain, for me. And so I became in love with it.
实际上是艺术表达的巅峰，因为你的词句必须富有诗意，制作设计和服装设计必须色彩斑斓。音乐也是其中的一部分。讲故事的元素，通过调动其他人来体现一个写下来并描述出来的创意的能量，对我来说，这就像是彻底榨干了我大脑的全部潜能。所以我彻底爱上了它。
And now this is my fourth directorial film. It's called One Spoon of Chocolate. Wait, this is your fourth film? This is my fourth one, yeah. Wow. And this one, probably my boldest one, pretty bold. Yeah. To kind of take a chance like this. And it took 13 years to get to this point. Like once I finished Man With an Iron Fist, I wanted like, so, you know, Universal gave me the money to make the movie, and it was like, you know, when it came out the first week,
现在这是我执导的第四部电影。它叫《一匙巧克力》。等等，这是你的第四部电影？这是我的第四部，对。哇。这部可以说是最大胆的一部，相当大胆。对，敢于冒这样的险。从萌生想法到走到这一步，花了13年时间。就像我拍完《铁拳》之后，我想，所以，你知道，环球影业给了我拍电影的资金，结果就是，你知道，当它上映的第一周，
I think Hurricane Sandy hit. And so, the East Coast was kind of fucked up for me. And so, I didn't hit the numbers we wanted to hit. I think we probably ended up around 30 million total in box office on a, sorry to talk numbers, that's when they kind of get me. We ended up about 30 million total in box office on a movie that cost about 17 million, right? Pretty good.
我想飓风桑迪袭来了。所以，东海岸对我的票房冲击挺大的。因此，票房没有达到我们预期的数字。我想我们最终的全球总票房大概在3000万左右，抱歉谈论数字，这正是他们能拿捏我的地方。我们最终在一部成本大约1700万的电影上拿到了大约3000万的总票房，对吧？相当不错。
Not, well, okay, not for Universal. For Universal, that's even. I paid the lights that day. We paid the lights. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, yeah. But I waited till it recouped before I went back and sat down with the executive who was in charge of gave me the green light, which is Mr. Adam Fogerson.
不，好吧，对环球影业来说不算。对环球影业来说，这只是打平。那天我们把电费挣回来了。我们把电费挣回来了。对，没错。对，对。但我一直等到它回本后，才回去和那位批准这个项目的主管坐下来谈，也就是亚当·福格森先生（Mr. Adam Fogerson）。
And I sat down and he said, you know, okay, you broke it. You did cool. Nobody's over here, you know, we're not jumping up and down nor are we sad, right. I said, okay, I got it now, I like to try another one. And so he said, okay, let me hear some ideas and I pitched the ideas and one of them was one spoon of chocolate.
我坐下来，他说，你知道，好吧，你回本了。你做得挺好。大家没有在这里，你知道，我们既没有欢呼雀跃，也没有闷闷不乐，对吧。我说，好吧，我现在明白了，我想再试一部。于是他说，好吧，让我听听你的一些想法，我提出了几个想法，其中一个就是《一匙巧克力》。
The other ones didn't really gravitate, but he said, that one seems like something you could chase. And then I started writing it, and I got writer's block, page 40. And it took almost, you know, this would be 13 years from the day of me starting it to it now being available. And it just kept taking time and time and time. And it didn't fully materialize until two summers ago,
其他的没有引起太大的共鸣，但他说，那一个听起来像是你可以去追寻的东西。然后我开始写剧本，结果到了第40页卡文了。几乎花了，你知道，从我开始写到它现在面世，整整经历了13年。它就这样不断地耗费着时间，时间，时间。直到两个夏天前，它才真正完全成型，
I'm on a tour bus with our Nas and we're doing the New York State of Mind, we're traveling across America, and my pen just started flowing. And so I wrote the whole movie. My wife was right beside me, just sitting right there. And we got home and I said, okay, I got a movie written. And we had a chance to, we had home and I said, okay, I got a movie written.
当时我和Nas在一辆巡演大巴上，我们在搞“纽约心境”（New York State of Mind）巡演，我们正在全美各地奔波，我的灵感突然如泉涌般喷发。于是我写完了整部电影。我妻子就坐在我旁边，安安静静地坐在那儿。我们回到家后，我说，好吧，我写好一部电影了。我们有机会，我们回到家后，我说，好吧，我写好一部电影了。
We had a chance to, you know, we had some good economics blessings in our lives. And so I said, well, she was looking at another house, so she likes to get nice houses and shit. That's kind of her thing. And so I said, well, I wrote the movie. You want to get another house or you want to make a movie? And she said, well, what do you want to do?
我们有机会，你知道，我们的生活中有一些不错的经济上的福分。所以我就说，当时她正在看另一栋房子，因为她喜欢买那种漂亮的豪宅什么的。这算是她的爱好吧。所以我就说，好吧，电影我写好了。你是想买另一栋房子，还是想拍一部电影？她就说，好吧，你想怎么做？
I said, to be honest, I really want to make a movie, like, with no interruptions, like, just go ahead and do it. And she said, okay, she gave me the green light, she's the producer of the film. Wow. Self-financed. Yeah, so she's, yeah, self-financed from, you know, leveraging some assets. And we did it. And we shot it in Atlanta,
我说，说实话，我真的很想拍一部电影，就像，没有任何干涉，就这样直接把它拍出来。她说，好，她给我开了绿灯，她是这部电影的制片人。哇。自筹资金。对，所以她是，对，是通过抵押一些资产来自筹资金。我们真的拍了。我们在亚特兰大进行了拍摄，
we finished it and it's going to premiere at the Tribeca Film Festival on June 8th. I'm super excited about it. That's awesome. And so are you going to be looking for distribution at that festival or have you already sold it? Yeah, it's going to be the first time we show it and we're looking for distribution,
我们完成了它，它将于6月8日在翠贝卡电影节上首映。我对此超级兴奋。太棒了。那你打算在那个电影节上寻找发行商，还是已经卖出去了？对，这将是我们的首映，我们正在寻找发行商，
so I hate to use the word hopefully, but hopefully. What's it about? What was the pitch you gave to Adam? And did it remain the same once you got past the page 40 or did it morph into something else? You know what? It actually, I guess without giving a spoiler,
所以我讨厌用“希望”这个词，但愿如此吧。这是讲什么的？你当时向亚当推销的创意是什么？当你写过第40页之后，它还是原来的构思，还是演变成别的东西了？你知道吗？它其实，我想在不剧透的情况下，
it morphed into 200 pages. Oh wow. Exactly. Yeah, for the listener usually a movie script is about 110. Yeah, it morphed into about 200 pages, and I think I got about 110 pages that we'll see when we look at this thing. That's amazing. And now Kill Bill was famously, what, 200 and something,
它演变成了200页的剧本。哦，哇。没错。是的，对于听众来说，通常一部电影剧本大概是110页。是的，它演变大约200页，我想最后我们精简出了大约110页呈现在这部电影里。太惊人了。话说《杀死比尔》当年也是，什么，200多页，
and so you had to split it up into two parts, right? Yeah, I actually read the 220 page Kill Bill. Yeah. Which, like I said, Tarantino is my professor. I call him my godfather of film. He's incredible. Love to have you on the show, Quentin, if you'll listen. Yeah, he's incredible.
所以你不得不把它分成上下两集，对吧？对，我确实读过那本220页的《杀死比尔》。对的，就像我说的，昆汀是我的教授。我称他为我电影界的教父。他太不可思议了。昆汀，如果你在听的话，很希望能邀请你来节目。对，他太不可思议了。
He's amazing. He's got to come to have you on the show, Quentin, if you'll excuse me. Yeah, he's incredible. He's amazing. He's got to come to us. He's got to. Yeah. But in other words, I'm always amazed when people like us, meaning that artists are in the entertainment business or whatever, that create the stuff like your films and music
他太棒了。他得来——如果你能原谅我的话，昆汀，很希望能邀请你来上节目。对，他太不可思议了。他太棒了。他必须要来找我们。他必须得来。对。但换句话说，每当看到像我们这样的人——意思是艺术家身处娱乐圈或诸如此类的地方，创作出像你们的电影和音乐
and everything else and us, TV shows, films, whatever we do, and that at some point in your life, you became aware of the business side of it. And what was that point, or who was that person where you're like, because when I was on the set of Will and Grace, it was a TV show I did a long time ago. Yeah, yeah, sure, sure. It's just something.
以及其他一切东西，还有我们，电视剧、电影，无论我们做什么，而在你人生的某个阶段，你开始意识到它的商业运作层面。那个时间点是什么时候？或者说，是哪个人让你意识到这一点，因为当我还在《威尔与格蕾丝》剧组时，那是我很久以前拍过的一部电视剧。对，对，当然，当然。这只是一段经历。
It's a lot of laughs, it's a lot of laughs. Hey, a masterpiece, a masterpiece. It took about five, six seasons for me to kind of look around. For it to get funny? Yeah. For me to look around and I was kind of like, wait a minute, I was really young and I was like, how did this all happen? Because I was just an actor who memorized my lines and showed up and went home.
那是充满欢笑的一段经历，充满了欢笑。嘿，一部杰作，一部杰作。我花了大约五六个季的时间才开始环顾四周。为了让它变得有趣？对。为了让我环顾四周，当时我有点像，等一下，我当时真的很年轻，我就在想，这一切是怎么发生的？因为我只是一个背台词、出工、然后回家的演员。
And then I was like, wait, how did this come together? Like, whose idea? And then the phone call. Then I got really interested, I was really young. I got interested in the business side of how to produce something and make something. So what was that moment for you? Or was there a person you were like, wait a minute,
然后我就在想，等等，这一切是怎么凑到一起的？是谁的主意？然后是那个电话。接着我对商业运作那一面产生了浓厚的兴趣，关于如何制作某样东西。所以对你来说，那个时刻是什么？或者说有没有哪个人让你觉得，等一下，
how did they do that? And then it kind of snowballed from there. Yeah, I think it was a couple of points for me, you know first in music of course, right as a producer No, you could control Let's just say like I said making an album. Maybe it's 20 people right, but when I was composing films The thing would kill bill is that I wasn't no wasn't going to be the composure. Let me
他们是怎么做到的？然后它就像滚雪球一样发展了起来。对，我觉得对我有几个关键点，你知道，首先是在音乐方面，当然，作为一个制作人，不，你可以掌控，比方说，就像我说的制作一张专辑。也许涉及20个人，但当我开始为电影配乐时，《杀死比尔》的情况是，我不会担任配乐师。让我
just be clear. Me and Quentin just used to watch movies together and he gave me that script and when I read the script of Kill Bill, it was just such an amazing script. I just said, yo, anything you may need from me, I'm here. I said also, I would love to see how you're going to bring this to life. At the time we were just buddies, film buddies. And he was like, yeah, sure. You know, if you show up on set, you know, you go be the guys, the eyes and ears behind me.
明确一下。我和昆汀以前只是经常一起看电影，他把那个剧本交给了我，当我读到《杀死比尔》的剧本时，那真是一个太棒的剧本了。我当时就说，兄弟，只要有需要我帮忙的，我随时都在。我还说，我也很想看看你是如何把这个故事搬上银幕的。当时我们只是哥们儿，电影之交。他便说，好啊，没问题。你知道的，如果你去片场，你知道，你就当我的眼睛和耳朵。
And now they were shooting in China and Beijing, but I showed up. And then I'm watching him, I'm watching Rob, Robert do the DP, and I'm the guy who's there with no job. So I got to study every job. I'm just chilling, hanging, watching the study, and I've realized that this was- And how old are you then? Oh, no, I'm a man, yeah. This is to kill Bill, I'm 32 at least, right?
当时他们正在中国北京拍摄，但我还是去了。然后我看着他，看着罗伯特（Rob）担任摄影指导（DP），而我是一个在那儿无所事事的人。所以我得研究每一个工作岗位。我只是在闲逛、观察、学习，我意识到这——你那时多大？哦，不，我已经是个成年人了，对。拍《杀死比尔》时，我至少32岁了，对吧？
30. So I'm a man. But I mean, I'm not a kid, meaning I was evolved as a, I guess you're going to say this too, Sean, right? You said after five or six years, right? You're not economically thinking about those problems no more, okay? Love is good in life most likely, right?
30岁。所以我已经是个成年人了。但我的意思是，我不是个小孩，这意味着我作为一个，我想你也会这么说吧，肖恩，对吧？你刚才说在五六年之后，对吧？你不再为那些经济问题发愁了，对吗？生活中的爱情多半也很美满，对吧？
Right. And the art is starting to really feel fulfilling, like a different type of fulfillment, almost a calling, right? So that's what's happening to me. My love life is good, my economics is good, and my art is insatiable though. It wants more, it wants more. And so that's what led me down that path. And then of course, as a businessman,
没错。而且艺术开始真正让人感到满足，那是一种不同类型的满足感，几乎就像一种召唤，对吧？所以这就是我当时的心境。我的感情生活很美满，我的经济状况很好，但我对艺术的渴望却永无止境。它想要更多，它想要更多。所以这就是引领我走上这条道路的原因。当然，作为一名商人，
I think, you know, if you go back and look at Wu Tangas, you know, from the beginning, we was entrepreneurs, you know, from opening up our clothing stores to video games, like all those things was just part of it. And then the last lesson for me, and I'll just share this with your audience, why that, you were saying, why the heck would you self-finance a film,
我想，如果你回顾一下武当帮（Wu-Tang）的历史，你知道，从一开始，我们就是企业家，从开设我们的服装店到电子游戏，所有这些事情都只是其中的一部分。然后对我来说的最后一课，我只想与你们的听众分享一下，为什么那个——你刚才说，为什么见鬼的你要自筹资金拍一部电影，
which is probably, everybody says don't do that. That's like in the book, there's a book on that. Okay. Right, right. It's the first chapter, yeah. Exactly, right. But, I got the chance from the year of 2018 to 2023 I got the chance from the year of 2018 to 2023 to be the show runner of my own TV show. Right?
这可能，每个人都说千万别这么做。这就好比行业指南书里写的。对，对。这就是第一章的内容，对吧。完全正确。但是，从2018年到2023年这段时间里，我有幸担任了自己电视剧的运作人（showrunner）。对吧？
Which one? It's Wu-Tang of the American Saga on Hulu. So during that show, it's just like, okay, the best way to do it is to do it. You know what I mean? The best way to do it is to do it. You know what I mean? The best way to do it is to do it. And so I'm in that philosophy. Because me spending a dollar may take somebody else $10 to spend that dollar because they don't know
哪一部？是Hulu上的《武当帮：美国传奇》（Wu-Tang: An American Saga）。所以在拍摄那部剧的过程中，这就好比，好吧，做这件事最好的方法就是直接去做。你知道我的意思吗？做这件事最好的方法就是直接去做。你知道我的意思吗？做这件事最好的方法就是直接去做。所以我践行着这种哲学。因为我花掉一美元，可能需要别人花十美元才能达到同样的效果，因为他们不知道
how to spend a dollar. All right. We'll be right back. And back to the show. You know, people who are as accomplished as you in as many different skill sets, it takes an enormous amount of not only ambition, but concentration and focus and discipline.
该怎么花这一美元。好的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。你知道，像你这样在这么多不同领域都取得如此巨大成就的人，不仅需要极其庞大的雄心，还需要惊人的专注力、注意力和自律。
Where, what would you say to the listeners who are trying to get their feet under themselves and really find that gear that it's gonna take to hit the passing lane and get past the folks that they're competing with? What is that special sauce for you and from whom did you learn it from or what happened that gave you that spark
那么，你会对那些正努力站稳脚跟、试图找到那种能冲进超车道并超越竞争对手的冲劲的听众说些什么呢？对你而言，那种特别的秘诀是什么？你是从谁身上学到这一点的，或者发生了什么事才让你获得了这种源源不断灵感、从而铸就如此多不可思议的杰作的动力？
that you tap into that has fueled so much incredible accomplished work? I will show anybody the first thing is mastery of something. If you master one thing and you mastered it, then you'll understand the relation of all things. Right? Because. And for me, you know, of course,
我会告诉任何人，首要的事情是对某事达到精通。如果你精通了一件事，并且真正掌握了它，那么你就会理解万物之间的联系。对吧？因为。对我来说，你知道，当然，
the first thing is going to be my lyrics, right? And I've been writing lyrics since the age of nine. So by the time, and you know, I'm the guy that finishes schoolwork first, so I can write another lyric. So mastery of your passion, I guess, should go together. Master your passion. That's great. And if you master your passion, I think that when it's time for other disciplines to come
首要的肯定是我的歌词，对吧？我从九岁起就开始写歌词了。所以等到，你知道的，我是那种最先写完学校作业的人，这样我就可以腾出时间写另一首歌词。所以，对热爱的精通，我想应该是齐头并进的。精通你的热爱。这太棒了。如果你精通了你的热爱，我想当其他领域的专业知识来到
amongst you, you're going to have a foundation because you'll be able to apply it. And I think we all can agree, us here, all of us artists right here, that we can say that it is, the artist has, I use this word, artistry is a wavelength, right? It's like, if you got a, so let's take a trumpet, right? And let's call the trumpet the artist. Whatever plays through that trumpet though, it could be jazz, soul, rock, pop, doesn't matter. It's going to come through that trumpet to turn it to music.
你身边时，你就会拥有一个坚实的基础，因为你能够将它应用起来。我想我们所有人都会同意，在座的各位，我们这里的每一位艺术家，我们都可以说，艺术，我用这个词，艺术性是一个波段，对吧？就像，如果你有一个，那么我们以小号为例，对吧？我们把小号比作艺术家。然而，无论什么音乐通过这把小号吹奏出来，它可以是爵士乐、灵魂乐、摇滚乐、流行乐，都没关系。它都会通过这把小号转化成音乐。
But when the artist knows the wavelength, he knows what to pass through his vessel. You know what I mean? Can you see that? You got cheese, man. I know. That's really cool. I know.
但当艺术家了解了这个波段，他就知道该让什么东西穿过他的容器。你知道我的意思吗？你能理解吗？你真有一套，老兄。我懂。这真的很酷。我懂。
Yeah, that's kind of amazing. Yeah, that's really cool. What if it's a piano? Just kidding. Uh... Sean's really cool. What if it's a piano? Just kidding. Uh. Sean's an accomplished pianist. I don't know if you knew that.
是的，这简直太惊人了。是的，这真的很酷。如果换成钢琴呢？开个玩笑。呃……肖恩真的很酷。如果换成钢琴呢？开个玩笑。呃……肖恩是一位才华横溢的钢琴家。我不知道你知不知道这一点。
He is. He really is. My favorite instrument, Sean. Okay, there you go. Yeah. We'll jam. How many can you play? How many different instruments?
他确实是。他真的是。肖恩，我最喜欢的乐器。好吧，那就对了。对。我们可以一起即兴演奏。你会弹多少种？你会多少种不同的乐器？
Yeah. I mean, I play, you know, I'm a producer, so producers a lot, technology, but I play guitar, drums, of course guitar and bass is no problem. I can blow some notes on my trumpet, and I spend a lot of time on the piano too. But I'm very shy on the piano, meaning mostly my wife gets to hear me. I got to be nice to play in front of an audience. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对。我的意思是，我会弹，你知道的，我是一个制作人，所以制作人懂很多科技手段，但我会弹吉他、鼓，当然吉他和贝斯都没问题。我还能用小号吹出几个音符，而且我在钢琴上也花了很多时间。不过我对钢琴感到很害羞，意思是通常只有我妻子能听到我弹。我必须得练得很棒才好在观众面前弹奏。对，对，对。
Sean's very coy on a piano. He's very coy. It's funny, you mentioned different instruments and stuff. You've done so many different, and you've done a lot of collabs in different genres. I remember you did that. I love that record you put out with Paul Banks from Interpol, Banks and Steel. I love Paul, yeah. I mean, dude, that was so rad, that record.
肖恩在弹钢琴时非常腼腆。他非常腼腆。很有意思，你提到了不同的乐器之类的。你做过那么多不同的尝试，而且你在不同的流派中做过很多合作。我记得你做过那个。我特别喜欢你和来自盘父乐队（Interpol）的保罗·班克斯（Paul Banks）合作的那张唱片，Banks and Steelz。我很喜欢保罗，对。我是说，老兄，那张唱片太酷了。
Talk a little bit about that experience and how you guys got together. Let's shout out Paul Banks first and the whole Interpol family. I put an Interpol song in Black Rabbit coming out. Well, congrats, man. Aw, that's dope. Yeah, thank you, thank you, thank you.
聊聊那段经历以及你们是怎么聚到一起的。让我们先向保罗·班克斯和整个Interpol家族致敬。我在即将上映的《黑兔》（Black Rabbit）里就用了一首Interpol的歌。哇，恭喜你，老兄。噢，太赞了。对，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。
And Paul's getting married this summer. Oh, is he? Oh, yeah? Yeah, I mean, this one of the coolest basslersachelors, I was married while he was making that album. He wasn't, you know what I mean? Yeah. And all the girls always scream for him. He's a cool dude, man. Oh, I mean, I don't know him, but I'm such a fan.
而且保罗今年夏天要结婚了。哦，是吗？哦，真的吗？对，我的意思是，这家伙曾经是世上最酷的黄金单身汉之一，我做那张专辑时已经结婚了而他还没有，你知道我的意思吗？对。而且所有的女孩总会为他尖叫。他是个很酷的家伙，老兄。哦，我的意思是，我不认识他，但我一直是他的超级粉丝。
Yeah, talk a little bit about that experience. Well, we met because he, I guess he had, he listened to some of my music and he was making it, he used, I guess one of his articles, he used me as a reference to something he was striving to do as an artist. And I think my manager read it and was like, oh, my manager's a fan of Paul. And he's like, oh, Paul is a fan of yours and he kind of quoted something about you. You guys are both New Yorkers, would you hook up?
对，聊聊那段经历吧。好吧，我们相遇是因为他，我想他听过我的一些音乐，他在创作时，我猜在他的一篇采访中，他把我作为他作为艺术家所追求的目标的一个参考。我想我的经纪人读到了那篇采访，然后就觉得，噢，我的经纪人是保罗的粉丝。他说，噢，保罗是你的粉丝，他引用了一些关于你的话。你们俩都是纽约客，要不要见个面？
I mean, he's not a native New Yorker, but he was living in New York at the time. He said, maybe you guys could hook up and chop it up. And we hooked up and we both were chess players. And so we would just play chess at the time. He did drink tequila. We met at a tequila bar. And that's tequila and chess.
我的意思是，他虽然不是土生土长的纽约客，但当时他住在纽约。他说，也许你们俩可以见个面，聊一聊。然后我们就见面了，我们俩都是国际象棋爱好者。所以当时我们就是一起下国际象棋。他喝龙舌兰酒。我们在一家龙舌兰酒吧见了面。就是龙舌兰酒加国际象棋。
And that built the friendship and maybe a couple of years later, I think Warner Brothers approached us and was like, would you guys be interested in kind of collaborating on something together? We just think you guys are just too cool motherfuckers just to be quite frank, was the slang they used. And we was like, yeah, whatever, yo, we hang anyway. Like you want us to do music too? Cool. You want to pass, hang up. I used that single, actually, as a temp track in my show.
这份友谊就是这么建立起来的，大概几年后，我想华纳兄弟找到我们并问：“你们有兴趣一起合作点什么吗？”他们用的俚语大概是：“我们觉得你们俩就是那种酷毙了的混蛋，坦白说。”我们当时就说：“行啊，无所谓，老兄，我们本来就经常一起玩。你想让我们也做音乐？没问题。你想路过，随便逛逛。”其实我在我的剧里就把那首单曲当成了临时配乐。
Chasen, you mentioned quite drolly Flake the other day, but we couldn't afford it. But we used it as a temp in the show. So I was a big fan. Oh no, anytime you can't afford show, so I was a big fan. When you... Oh no, anytime you can't afford something of mine, just hit me up. I'm gonna hit you from now on.
查森，你前几天幽默地提到了片酬太高，但我们当时真的负担不起。不过我们把它当成了剧里的临时配乐。所以我一直是他的大粉丝。哦不，任何时候只要你负担不起我——剧里的配乐，所以我一直是你的大粉丝。当你们……哦不，任何时候只要你负担不起我的东西，尽管来找我。我从今以后要找你算账了。
Yeah, I discount so many things and one dollar gratis. If it gets to my desk, it gets easier. If it don't get to my desk, they don't smack it. I'm gonna take you up on that. I'm coming. Hey, did you score your four films that you directed? No, I scored two. I scored the first one with my buddy Howard Drossin.
对，我有很多东西都可以打折，甚至一美元免费赠送。只要这事能落到我桌上，事情就好办多了。如果没落到我桌上，他们就不会轻易放过。那我可要记下你这句话了。我这就来。嘿，你执导的那四部电影，配乐都是你自己做的吗？没有，我做了两部。第一部是我和我的好朋友霍华德·德罗斯辛（Howard Drossin）合作配乐的。
The second one, Richard Gibbs, me and him collaborated on the second one. The third one I passed over to Danny Harrison, good friend, George Harrison's son, him and his crew did it. And on the fourth one, I actually combined with Tyler Bates, which is, I think Tyler's an incredible composer, just bold and brave in his sound selection.
第二部，理查德·吉布斯（Richard Gibbs），我和他合作完成了第二部。第三部我交给了丹尼·哈里森（Danny Harrison），一个好朋友，乔治·哈里森的儿子，他和他的团队完成了。到了第四部，我实际上是和泰勒·贝茨（Tyler Bates）合作的，我觉得泰勒是一位不可思议的作曲家，他的音色选择既大胆又勇敢。
So the fourth film is me and Tyler together. Wow. I wanna see that film. I know, me too. Yeah, go ahead, Jason, you had a follow-up. Well, I was unrelated, but one thing that I keep forgetting to ask, what about- Oh, sorry, this is our new segment we're doing called Unrelated, go ahead, Jason, you had a follow-up. Well, I was unrelated, but one thing I keep forgetting to ask. Oh, sorry, this is our new segment we're doing called Unrelated.
所以第四部电影是我和泰勒共同完成的。哇。我想看那部电影。我懂，我也想看。对，说吧，杰森，你还有一个后续问题。哦，这跟刚才无关，但我一直忘了解——哦，抱歉，这是我们的新环节，叫“无关话题”，请继续，杰森，你还有一个后续问题。哦，这跟刚才无关，但我有一件事一直忘了解——哦，抱歉，这是我们的新环节，叫“无关话题”。
Go ahead. Yeah. I like it. What about martial arts for you? Are you an accomplished martial artist or is there any crossover there? That's a big word, accomplished. Look, no, I wouldn't say that. I don't know, right?
请继续。对。我喜欢这个。关于武术，对你来说是怎么样的？你是一位造诣深厚的武术家吗，或者这其中有什么相通之处吗？“造诣深厚”这个词可太重了。听着，不，我不会这么说。我不知道，对吧？
Of course, I practice martial art. You do, okay. Yeah, but my philosophy is mental martial art, cultural, artistic martial arts. You know what I mean? It's, you know, just to give you a little bit about the Wu-Tang philosophy in the martial world. So the Shaolin philosophy is known to be external, right?
当然，我练习武术。你练过，好吧。对，但我的哲学是精神武术、文化艺术武术。你知道我的意思吗？就是，为了向你们简单介绍一下武当哲学在武术世界中的地位。少林哲学被认为是外家功夫，对吧？
You train your body to be hard as iron, right? In the Wu-Tang, you train your body to be soft as cotton. The Shaolin martial artist would roll a thousand punches a day. The Wu-Tang martial artist would sit still and contemplate the thousand punches in his mind. So, exercising the mind is known as, because it's kind of Taoist,
你训练你的身体坚硬如铁，对吧？而在武当，你训练你的身体柔软如棉。少林武术家一天要打一千拳。武当武术家则会静坐冥想，在心中演练那一千拳。所以，锻炼心智被称为，因为它有点道家的色彩，
so it's known as that's the Wu-Tang way, but exercising the body is Zen or Buddhist way. So, being a Wu-Tang abbot, I'm going here. And so that's why my lyrics or my art is always formulating. Now somebody was a step to me now. Okay. Okay.
所以这被认为是武当的方式，而锻炼身体则是禅宗或佛教的方式。所以，作为一名武当方丈，我走的是这条路。这就是为什么我的歌词或我的艺术总是在不断演变。现在如果有人想向我挑战。好吧。好吧。
It's a mistake. Yeah, yeah, so Shaolin's going to jump up out of me. You know what I mean? Dude, dude, I am entranced. I am now, this is like unbelievable. This is so. I'm going into a. I am now, this is like unbelievable. I'm going into a Wu-Tang cave when this interview's over. I've been into Wu-Tang, we were supposed to record
那可就大错特错了。对，对，所以少林功夫会从我身上瞬间爆发出来。你知道我的意思吗？老兄，老兄，我听得入迷了。我现在，这简直太不可思议了。这太……我要进入一个。我现在，这简直太不可思议了。等这次采访结束，我要去一个武当洞穴里闭关。我一直在接触武当，我们本该在
a little while ago, I've been into Wu-Tang, just absolute cave for months now. Hey, speaking of Wu-Tang, and just your music in general, do you see, you guys have been so, like I said, you're so influential on other musicians for the last over 30 years. Can you see, can you like catch glimpses of your influence in music now when you listen to hip hop?
不久前录音的，我一直在研究武当，简直像在山洞里闭关了好几个月一样。嘿，说到武当，以及你的整体音乐，你觉得，你们一直都是，就像我说的，在过去的30多年里，你们对其他音乐人产生了如此深远的影响。当你听嘻哈音乐时，你能看到、捕捉到你们对当今音乐影响的蛛丝马迹吗？
Yeah, definitely. I mean, it's a blessing, right, to be able to inspire anything or anybody, right, after getting inspiration from life yourself. But yeah, it's, you know, constantly, you know, Some of our greatest artists, they are not shy to give us a name drop. I mean Drake named the song Wu-Tang forever. One of Kendrick Lamar's first samples was a RZA sample, which I cleared for free. Nice, nice, nice. Very good, very good. Nice, nice, nice.
对，绝对能。我的意思是，这是一种福分，对吧，在从生活本身获得灵感之后，还能去启发任何事或任何人，对吧？但是的，你知道的，不断的，你知道的，我们最伟大的艺术家中，有些人从不吝啬对我们进行名字致敬。我的意思是，德雷克（Drake）写了一首歌叫《永远的武当》（Wu-Tang Forever）。坎耶·韦斯特或者说坎昆·拉玛（Kendrick Lamar）最早的采样之一就是一个RZA采样，我免费为他清除了版权。太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。非常好，非常好。太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。
Very good, very good. You're welcome, man. You guys did so much sampling over the years. I mean, you guys were like the masters of it. Was there ever a sample that you couldn't clear, that you wished you could have gotten and you were not able to get? What was, no, the worst, no, I want to say that I,
非常好，非常好。不客气，老兄。你们这些年来做了那么多的采样。我的意思是，你们就像是这方面的专家。有没有哪个采样是你无法清除版权，但你又非常希望能够得到、却最终没能如愿的？有没有，不，最糟糕的是，不，我想说的是，
let me see, yeah, there was a couple. Because some people would like become born-again Christians become born again Christians and they wasn't letting hip hop go. But one of my biggest glitches was this, and I don't mind sharing this with your audience, is that there's no floor or ceiling when it comes to sampling and interpolation rights. And I totally disagree with that. The reason why I disagree is because if you sample a song, say you sample a James Brown song and you got Bootsy on bass, but you got all these different people playing Maceo,
让我想想，对，有那么几个。因为有些人会变成重生基督徒，变成重生基督徒后，他们就不肯放过嘻哈音乐。但我最大的痛点之一是这个，我不介意和你们的听众分享，那就是在采样和改编权方面，是没有下限也没有上限的。而我完全不同意这一点。我之所以不同意，是因为如果你采样了一首歌，比方说你采样了一首詹姆斯·布朗（James Brown）的歌，有博西（Bootsy）弹贝斯，但你还有所有这些不同的人在演奏梅西奥（Maceo）的部分，
they all playing, the publisher will come and could potentially take 100% of that song away from you. Right? And say that because you're copyright infringing. And even though your song could be almost unrecognizable from their song. And then the musicians who, you're probably more into the musicians than the song itself. Like if I sampled a little bass part from here, a little horn from this guy, a little snare from this guy, and me, I'm the type of guy that had Peter Pan records, so I may get a string section from that,
他们都在演奏，版权方就会找上门来，并有可能夺走这首歌100%的版权。对吧？并声称你侵犯了版权。尽管你的歌听起来可能和他们的歌完全听不出有什么联系。而那些音乐人，你其实更欣赏音乐人本身而不是歌曲本身。比如如果我从这里采样了一小段贝斯，从那个家伙那里采样了一小段管乐，从另一个家伙那里采样了一小段小军鼓，而我呢，我是那种拥有彼得潘唱片（Peter Pan Records）的人，所以我可能会从中弄一段弦乐，
you know what I mean? And make a track. So it's like, what about those musicians? They never get compensated. It's just the publishing company. And then I said this last, to me in my opinion, that it should be a floor and a ceiling. The ceiling should be 50%.
你知道我的意思吗？然后制作出一首音轨。所以问题是，那些音乐人怎么办？他们从来没有得到过报酬。只有出版公司拿钱。然后我最后说的是，在我看来，应该有一个下限和一个上限。上限应该是50%。
That should be the ceiling. You should never take more than half, because you got the lyrics, you got the talent, you got everything else that the other person is building to make the song, right? And then the floor should be then prorated by how much you took versus what the song is.
那应该是上限。你绝不应该拿走超过一半的版权，因为你拥有歌词、才华以及其他人为了创作这首歌而建立的一切，对吧？然后下限应该根据你取用了多少与歌曲本身的比例来进行按比例折算。
But with a ceiling, so the floor could be, I'll put the floor at even 20% to be merciful. 20% floor, no matter what, if you put my record on, you take something, give me 20% for that inspiration. But most I could take from you, it's 50%, and we'll measure how to get to 50%. I got a situation where I did sample Marvin Gaye and Tammy Terrell's All I Need, and it was a double platinum selling song. Juan DeGrammy, Method Man, and Mary J. Blige. It was a Coca-Cola commercial of the summer, And all we received is 10% of the song.
但有了上限之后，下限就可以是，为了仁慈起见，我把下限定在20%。20%的下限，无论如何，如果你用了我的唱片，你拿走了某些东西，为此给我20%的灵感报酬。但我能从你那里拿走的最多的比例是50%，我们会衡量如何达到50%。我曾遇到过这样的情况，我采样了马文·盖伊（Marvin Gaye）和塔米·特雷尔（Tammy Terrell）的《All I Need》，那是一首双白金销量的歌曲。荣获格莱美奖，由方法人（Method Man）和玛丽·J·布莱姬（Mary J. Blige）演唱。那是那个夏天可口可乐的广告曲，而我们最终只得到了这首歌10%的版权。
They took it all. Wow. Yeah, and that song made, yeah. Every time it made a dollar, they only gave us a dime. No way. Look, and one, I could argue back, they said it was ours, you took it.
他们把其余的都拿走了。哇。是的，那首歌赚了，是的。每当它赚一美元，他们只给我们一毛钱。不会吧。听着，一方面，我可以反驳他们，他们说那是我们的，你们拿了。
But also, I could then argue back, but no, we didn't know. We didn't know that that was a law or, cause hip hop started from a guy with a turntable and he's scratching beats back and forth. We rapping over it. Then they made a sampler. The sampler says, sampling instrument.
但另一方面，我也可以反驳，不，我们不知道。我们不知道那是一条法律，或者说，因为嘻哈音乐始于一个拿着唱盘、来回刮擦节拍的家伙。我们在上面说唱。然后他们发明了采样器。采样器就叫采样乐器。
Okay, that's my new instrument. And now I'm sampling sounds and records from my collection and I'm making my own thing. We didn't know that it was going to be a law or some type of thing that was going to stop us. And eventually hip hop got slowed down because of sampling and interpolation laws. Because of lawyers.
好吧，那是我的新乐器。现在我从我的收藏中采样各种声音和唱片，我在创作我自己的东西。我们当时并不知道这会成为一条法律，或者某种会阻碍我们的东西。最终，嘻哈音乐因为采样和改编法律而发展放缓了。都是因为律师。
Yeah, and then all those fees were assessed retroactively in all of those songs that were created with some samples and stuff. Once the law went into effect, then they reached back and charged, oh wow. You got some songs now, I got a song of mine that is totally wrong, two or three of my songs, because they thought that it was it, and it wasn't it.
是的，然后所有这些费用都被追溯评估到了所有那些包含采样的歌曲中。一旦法律生效，他们就会回溯并索取费用，哦，哇。你现在有些歌，我有一首自己的歌，完全被搞砸了，有两三首我的歌，因为他们以为那是原曲，结果根本不是。
Wow, wow. And it's like, hold on, that's not Roger Troutman. What is? I didn't even, I wasn't a Roger Troutman fan. Right? I was a Thelonious Monk fan, but I wasn't a Roger Troutman fan. I love that. I love your floor and ceiling idea.
哇，哇。这就好像，等一下，那根本不是罗杰·特劳特曼（Roger Troutman）。那是什幺？我甚至连，我都不是罗杰·特劳特曼的粉丝。对吧？我是塞隆尼斯·孟克（Thelonious Monk）的粉丝，但我不是罗杰·特劳特曼的粉丝。我太喜欢这个了。我非常喜欢你提出的“上下限”的概念。
I think that that's something that should take root. Hopefully, I think that that makes a lot of sense and seems really fair. Really, really fair. So I hope that works out. All right, before I let you go, I want to talk a little bit about a ballet through Mud because you released a classical album last year.
我觉得这应该生根发芽。希望如此，我觉得这很有意义，而且看起来非常公平。真的非常非常公平。所以我希望这个想法能行得通。好的，在我放你离开之前，我想聊聊关于《泥潭芭蕾》（Ballet through Mud）的事情，因为你去年发行了一张古典专辑。
I can't, I did not know this. I want to hear this. It's unbelievable. Like every time there's like something else that you did, talk a little bit about how that came about and your ambition with that. And where we can see it. Will it ever be done again?
我简直，我竟然不知道这件事。我很想听听这个。这太不可思议了。好像你总是能做出一些别出心裁的新东西，跟我们聊聊这个项目的由来以及你当时的雄心。我们在哪里可以看到它？以后还会再次上演吗？
Well, the ballet was performed a few times already, and so we don't know if it's going to, if I'm going to do it again, like perform it again, but we did perform it in L.A. We did in Colorado, which we, I wrote it for Colorado. I was part of this artist in residence where for three years I would create something to take to the Colorado Symphony Orchestra and perform. So it was during the pandemic, of course, that I found this notebook of old lyrics. And then inside these lyrics, these are like my high school lyrics. So this book is so old, my buddy Ray Quar made a joke,
嗯，这部芭蕾舞剧已经上演过好几次了，所以我们还不知道它会不会，我是说我会不会再次把它搬上舞台，再次表演它，但我们确实在洛杉矶表演过。我们还在科罗拉多表演过，我是为科罗拉多创作的。我曾参与一个驻场艺术家项目，连续三年我都要创作一些作品带到科罗拉多交响乐团进行表演。当然，正是在疫情期间，我找到了这本装满旧歌词的笔记本。然后在这本歌词里，这些都是我高中时期的歌词。所以这本书太古老了，我的好朋友雷·夸尔（Ray Quar）还开玩笑说，
said that book is growing hair, man. Like, it's that old, right? But in it is all of the ideas from ninth grade up into graduation. Right, so you could hear, you could see the first blunt, the first weed, you could hear the early sexual ideas and everything, and you could also hear the imagination growing.
说那本书都快长毛了，老兄。就是那么古老，对吧？但在里面记录了我从九年级到毕业所有的创意。对吧，所以你能听到，你能看到我抽的第一口大麻，抽的第一口草，能听到我早期青涩的性观念以及一切，你还能听到我不断生长的想象力。
And so when I found the book, I said, I can't rap these, what should I do? And then I eventually decided, talking to my wife about it of course, that what if I composed it into a ballet or something? And so she thought it was a great idea as well. And I kind of went into it. The funny thing is that,
所以当我找到这本书时，我说，我不能把这些唱出来，我该怎么办？然后我最终决定，当然是跟我妻子商量之后，如果我把它谱曲变成一部芭蕾舞剧或者别的什么会怎么样？她也觉得这是个绝妙的主意。于是我就着手去做了。有趣的是，
let me share one of the lyrics that led to it, okay? So one of the lyrics was about these six teenagers who are exploring life, right? So Sue was this girl who was really quite fly, and Brad was real cool, he was her guy. Lisa was freaky, she loved to have sex. Her brother name was Dexter, but they called him Dex. His girlfriend name was Monica, she was a verge.
让我分享一下其中一首启发了这个作品的歌词，好吗？所以其中一首歌词是关于六个正在探索生活的青少年的故事，对吧？苏（Sue）是一个非常时髦的女孩，布拉德（Brad）真的很酷，他是她的男朋友。丽莎（Lisa）很疯狂，她热爱性爱。她哥哥名叫德克斯特（Dexter），但大家都叫他德克斯（Dex）。他女朋友叫莫妮卡（Monica），还是个处女。
And Joe, he was their friend, and he was a nerd. Brad bought the beer, Sue bought the smoke, Lisa had sheets, Dexter had coke. Joe was the type who didn't get high, nor did Monica, but she was willing to try. So Brad lit a blunt and passed it to Joe saying, come on man, smoke it. And Joe said, no.
而乔（Joe），他是他们的朋友，是个书呆子。布拉德买啤酒，苏买大麻，丽莎带了床单，德克斯特带了可卡因。乔是那种不吸毒也不嗨的人，莫妮卡也是，但她愿意尝试一下。于是布拉德点燃了一支大麻烟递给乔，说，来吧，兄弟，抽一口。乔说，不。
What's wrong? Are you scared? Was asked by Sue. Oh, you were just a nerd. Joe said, that's not true. Monica said, come on Joe, just have a taste. And she poked on the joint and blew smoke in his face. Now on Monica, Joe had a crush. He didn't want to do it but felt that he must.
怎么了？你害怕了吗？苏这样问他。噢，你只是个书呆子。乔说，才不是呢。莫妮卡说，来吧，乔，尝一口嘛。她抽了一口大麻，把烟吐在他脸上。对于莫妮卡，乔其实暗恋已久。他其实不想抽但觉得不得不抽。
Like many we know, love made him a fool so he smoked the joint to prove he was cool. Then Lisa was like yo forget about Joe. Then say hey Dex, where the heck is the blow? He pulled out two grams, said it's all that I bought. Well it's more than enough and they proceeded to snort. Now with this time, Joe had finished two beers, and Brad was like, here, have another, you queer.
就像我们认识的很多人一样，爱情让他变成了一个傻瓜，所以他抽了大麻来证明自己很酷。然后丽莎就说，噢，别管乔了。然后说，嘿，德克斯，粉在哪里？德克斯掏出两克，说这就是我买的全部了。好吧，这足够多了，然后他们开始吸食。与此同时，乔已经喝了两杯啤酒，布拉德就说，来，再喝一杯，你这个胆小鬼。
And Joe said no while holding his stomach, and while facing Monica, he suddenly vomited. She screamed, oh my God, shit, how I've served. And everyone laughed and said, Joe is a nerd, Joe is a nerd, Joe is a nerd. Joe felt embarrassed, so he did the bird. They chased him, he ran. They screamed and they laughed into this abandoned house
乔捂着肚子说不，正对着莫妮卡，突然吐了。她尖叫道，哦天哪，妈的，我真倒霉。大家哈哈大笑，说，乔是个书呆子，乔是个书呆子，乔是个书呆子。乔感到很尴尬，于是竖起了中指。他们追他，他跑了。他们尖叫着笑着跑进了一座废弃的房子里，
and with the sound of this crashing glass. And it was dark in there, so Brad had to get a light to check to see if Joe was all right. But when they found him, he was laying on his back with quarts of red blood spurting from his head. And Monica said, oh my God, Joey is dead. And they started to run and they never mentioned this incident again to anyone.
伴随着玻璃破碎的声音。里面很黑，所以布拉德不得不拿个灯来查看乔是否安然无恙。但当他们找到他时，他正仰面躺着，红色的鲜血从他的头部喷涌而出。莫妮卡说，哦天哪，乔伊死了。他们吓得逃跑了，从此再也没有向任何人提起过这件事。
So. Wow. That's beautiful. That is amazing. And I turned that to a ballet. That's unbelievable. Oh, gotta see that. Just riveted.
所以。哇。太美妙了。这太惊人了。我把这个改编成了一部芭蕾舞剧。这简直难以置信。哦，我一定要去看。完全被迷住了。
How in the world do you remember, not only remember that, but remember everything that you make? I mean, it's unbelievable. Oh, I've gotta see that. Just riveted. How in the world do you remember, not only remember that, but remember everything that you make? I mean, it's incredible. It's so good. Yeah, God, man, we can talk for hours. We've taken up way too much of your time. What an absolute, like I said at the beginning, what an absolute honor to have you, man.
你到底是怎么做到不仅能记住这些，还能记住你创作的一切的？我的意思是，这太不可思议了。噢，我一定要去看。完全被迷住了。你到底是怎么做到不仅能记住这些，还能记住你创作的一切的？我的意思是，这太惊人了。太棒了。是的，天哪，老兄，我们可以聊上几个小时。我们已经占用了你太多时间了。正如我一开始所说的，能邀请到你真是无上的荣幸，老兄。
I'm such a fan. Yeah, it really has been. It really has been. You're such a creative juggernaut, dude, in every way. So just continue to success. Thank you. Thanks for coming. And I send all respect, and I just say now,
我是你的超级粉丝。是的，真的太棒了。确实如此。你在方方面面都是一个极具创造力的巨无霸，老兄。所以祝你继续取得成功。谢谢。谢谢你能来。我向你致以崇高的敬意，我想说的是，
I'm a fan of all you guys' work as well. Thank you for what you contributed to my life. It's just, you know, I've watched you, I've watched as a fan, you know, the things you guys create, whether in the theater or in front of my TV set, and got my laughs, got my inspiration, and probably took something from your tree here and there, because I'm hip hop, so I sampled.
我也同样是你们各位作品的粉丝。谢谢你们为我的生命所做出的贡献。这只是，你知道的，我一直在注视着你们，我作为你们的粉丝，注视着你们创作的东西，无论是在剧院里还是在我的电视机前，带给我欢笑，给我灵感，可能还从你们的艺术之树上顺手摘下了一些果实，因为我是玩嘻哈的，所以我用了采样。
Yeah, you sampled us, you sampled us. I sampled, yes, indeed. I appreciate it. Right back at you, you've touched all of us, millions and millions around the world, too, so thank you for what you do. You really inspired us today. Well, thank you, RZAzo for your time, man.
是的，你们采样了我们，你们采样了我们。我采样了，是的，确实如此。我很感激。同样地，你也深深影响了我们，还有全世界千千万万的人，所以谢谢你所做的一切。你今天真的激励了我们。好的，谢谢RZA抽出时间，兄弟。
Thank you guys. And yeah, spoonful of chocolate. All the best luck with it, man. Can't wait for it. We'll be watching. Respect. Peace. Thank you.
谢谢你们。祝《一匙巧克力》一切顺利，老兄。等不及要看了。我们一定会看的。致敬。和平。谢谢。
Peace. Bye, pal. Wow, Willie. That was, I didn't think you had it in you. You know, you always talk about them. You've talked about them forever. We looked in climate and had them. And I wanted to have them on for a long time. And I'm so, I'm like, I knew the bar was high.
和平。再见，老兄。哇，威利。那真是，我没想到你还有这一手。你知道，你总是在谈论他们。你谈论他们已经很久了。我们研究过克莱门特（Climate）并且邀请到了他们。我早就想邀请他们来上节目了。而且我太，我觉得，我知道标准很高。
I was like, oh, he's gonna be inspirational. He's gonna be cool. And I can't believe how he just exceeds expectations just as a creative, right? It's just unbelievable. It's like an endless well of creativity. Yeah, and also like just philosophies and like, yeah, I mean, spiritual, like, I love the thing
我就想，噢，他一定会带来很多启示。他一定会很酷。我简直不敢相信他作为一名创作者，是如何超越所有期望的，对吧？这简直不可思议。就像一个用之不竭的创意源泉。是的，还有那些人生哲学，是的，我的意思是，精神层面的，我很喜欢那个
you said about the trumpet, like where the artist has to connect the energy to the vibrations that go through the thing that makes the sound, like whatever that was, but that was really cool. Yeah, we're like trumpet, Jay, you're more like a Waymo, you know what I mean? You're just like a automated car with nothing inside. So, an empty vehicle that goes from just
你刚才提到小号，就好像艺术家必须把能量连接到穿过发声部件的振动上，无论那是什么，但这真的很酷。是的，我们就像小号，杰伊，你更像是一辆Waymo，你知道我的意思吗？你就像一辆里面什么都没有的自动驾驶汽车。所以，一辆空车，从仅仅
destination to destination, but that's fine. That's fine, and we still love you. But honestly, yeah, he had so many, you're right, he had so many cool philosophies. I mean, I could be. By the way, the whole Shaolin approach that he does and the way they created that community and kind of like there's just,
目的地到目的地，但没关系。没关系，我们依然爱你。但说实话，是的，他有那么多，你说得对，他有那么多酷炫的哲学。我的意思是，我可以。顺便说一句，他采用的整套少林方法，以及他们建立那个社区的方式，还有那种感觉，就是，
and he produced all those records for all those guys, for Ghostface and for all those dudes like Method Man, it's insane. It is wild. I want to be in the music world a little bit. They all just seem like they just, they kind of got it all together. They're super chill.
他为所有那些家伙制作了所有的唱片，为Ghostface，还有像Method Man这样的那些家伙，这太疯狂了。这太狂野了。我有点想进入音乐界了。他们所有人看起来都像是，他们，他们把一切都搞定了。他们超级冷静。
Yeah, no one's running. They're just, you know, they're just doing their thing. I'm really excited for him. I knew Jay, you'd be excited that he's directing. I didn't know he'd done four films, but I saw the trailer for his new film. It looks really, really good. Yeah, yeah.
是的，没人跑步。他们只是，你知道的，他们只是在做他们的事情。我真的为他感到兴奋。我知道杰伊，你会为他执导电影感到兴奋。我不知道他拍了四部电影，但我看了他新电影的预告片。看起来真的很不错。是的，是的。
So I'm excited for that and how cool. And it makes sense that he'd be a good director because he has been sort of the Abbott, as he says, of the Wu Tang for so long and does so many, and wears so many hats and Jays, you know, as a director, that's what you have to do. Pulling on all those different levers, yeah. And just a great leader.
所以我为此感到兴奋，而且这太酷了。他能成为一个好导演是合情合理的，因为正如他所说，他长期以来一直像是武当的“方丈”，做了那么多事情，身兼数职，而杰伊，你知道的，作为一个导演，这就是你必须要做的。掌控所有那些不同的杠杆，是的。而且他真是一个伟大的领导者。
I've spent a lot of time on Abbott Kinney when there's a gay bar in Abbott Kinney. You know, funny story about that gay bar, it's called the Roosterfish. The Roosterfish. I think, I think, I think. How do you guys know that?abor. It's called the rooster So when I When I I like all about in the back alley behind anyway forget
我在阿博特·金尼（Abbott Kinney）度过了很多时间，那里有一家同性恋酒吧。你知道关于那家同性恋酒吧的一个有趣的故事吗，它叫Roosterfish。Roosterfish。我想，我想，我想。你们怎么知道那个的？它叫rooster。所以当我和When我喜欢所有的在后巷后面不管怎样忘了吧
I used to live right around there and When I first moved into my house me and my buddy went down went down like, well we gotta find our local bar, right? If we're gonna be living down here. And this place is, at the time, I don't know if it still is, it was painted this really cool turquoise blue. And we're like, well this place looks kinda cool. Walked in there, sat at the bar, and ordered a couple of beers,
我以前就住在那个附近，当我刚搬进我的房子时，我和我的哥们去了，去了，就觉得，我们得找到我们当地的酒吧，对吧？如果我们打算住在这里的话。这个地方，当时我不知道现在是不是，它被刷成了这种非常酷的绿松石蓝色。我们想，这个地方看起来挺酷的。走了进去，坐在吧台旁，点了两杯啤酒，
and just started talking to each other. And I get a little tap tap on the shoulder. I don't think the guy had like a gag ball in his mouth but it seemed it was something was it was very clear that we were in the wrong spot. Yeah. Almost immediately. Right, right. We finished the beer and we shook hands.
然后开始聊天。我感到肩膀被轻轻拍了一下。我不觉得那家伙嘴里塞着口球，但看起来确实是某种东西，非常清楚我们走错地方了。是的。几乎是立刻。对，对。我们喝完啤酒，握了握手。
Sure, you got another one. Yeah. So we only had three more beers. I only had three more and then I was out of there. By the way, I forgot to mention that, for Rizza, that they're on tour this summer, right, the Wu Tang final tour, so I also wanted to mention that. Yeah, yeah, yeah, we should go, we should really go.
当然，你又来了一杯。是的。所以我们只多喝了三杯啤酒。我只多喝了三杯，然后我就离开了。顺便说一句，我忘了提，对于Rizza来说，他们今年夏天在巡演，对吧，武当的最后巡演，所以我还想提一下。是的，是的，是的，我们应该去，我们真的应该去。
How fun. Why didn't you mention that during the interview so we could lock up some tickies? I know, I forgot, we can still lock up tickies. Please don't say tickies. Why do you fucked up do you got? Yeah, why didn't you mention that during the interview so we could lock up some tickies? I know, I forgot. We can still lock up. Please don't say tickies. Why little tickies? Look, he picked it up from Roosterfish.
多有趣啊。你为什么不在采访时提一下，这样我们就能弄到一些门票（tickies）了？我知道，我忘了，我们还是可以弄到门票的。请别说“tickies”。你有什么毛病？是的，你为什么不在采访时提一下，这样我们就能弄到一些门票了？我知道，我忘了。我们还是可以弄到。请别说“tickies”。为什么是小门票？看，他是从Roosterfish那里学来的。
Why do you have to do that? He picked it up from Roosterfish. That's the way I would have phrased it with him, too. I say, hey, any chance we get some tickies? You know, and it would have been uncomfortable. Ambush him in the interview live. You know, he would have had to give us those tickies. That would have been uncomfortable for anybody, dude.
你为什么非要那样做？他是从Roosterfish那里学来的。这也是我跟他说话时会用的语气，你知道的，我会说，嘿，我们有没有机会弄到一些门票？你知道的，那会很尴尬。在采访中现场伏击他。你知道的，他不得不给我们那些门票。这对任何人来说都会很尴尬，老兄。
Okay, now say it is. The way you sort of infantilize everything is so gross. I wanna, by the way, I feel like that Rooster Fish story isn't over, but well, it can be for now. I'll tell you the ending after we come through, after we shut down. That was the day that you discovered that you weren't gay,
好吧，现在说是的。你把一切都幼稚化的方式太令人反感了。顺便说一句，我觉得那个Rooster Fish的故事还没结束，不过现在可以先结束了。等我们播完，节目关闭后，我会告诉你结局。那是你发现自己并不是同性恋的那一天，
but that maybe you were gay adjacent. Bye! There he is. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
但也许你与同性恋有着某种邻近关系。再见！他来了。聪明。无。聪明。无。聪明。无。聪明。无。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
聪明。无。聪明。无。聪明。无。聪明。无。
Smart. Less. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。无。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armgerf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armgerf 100%有机手工制作。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。